Moin Leute, Pogörs, ja Stream ein bisschen außer der Reihe, ich habe gedacht, wenn wir jetzt schon den restlichen Tag Warzone spielen, mache ich einfach mal den Stream an, ich weiß, dass nicht so viele Leute am Start sind, die Warzone gucken wollen, aber ich denke mal, wenn ich hier den ganzen Tag da bin, warum nicht, je nachdem wie lange wir spielen, machen wir nachher vielleicht noch sowas, ansonsten, ansonsten nicht, mal gucken, wer ist denn schon da, der Kelmo ist am Start, Gameshock auch da, huge,
meine Tastatur-Settings sind kaputt, so, wir müssen mal Teamspeak imbuten, Leute, ihr glaubt sich, wir sind im Teamspeak, Alter, ne, so, auf geht's, also ich habe Stream an, ne, nur zur Info,
oh Gott, was sage ich, der Pi, ich bin richtig nervös, ja, jetzt können wir uns nicht mehr erlauben, hier Scheiße zu bauen, aber wir gewinnen halt, ich will nicht, dass wir nur reportet werden,
ne, komm, wir haben heute, wir haben heute zwei, drei, wie viele Games haben wir gespielt, drei Games und eins gewonnen, ja, heute Vormittag haben wir ja auch noch zwei gespielt, komm, lass uns mal mitzählen, aber, 33% Winrate, easy,
ja, Top 10 zählt für mich halt, vollzeit Stream, so sagt der Chat, ne, nicht wirklich, wie spricht man diese Map eigentlich aus, Verdansk,
es ist niederländisch, es ist in einem Fantasieland, wenn du eine Kampagne spielst, ist es so, quasi Russland, oh, huge, ey, wow, wow, Alter, oh, oh, oh, mehr russischer Akzent,
bitte, ach, muss man das russisch aussprechen, Verdansk, ja, ich kann auf Russisch bloß, привет, hallo, mein Freund, ich bin Russ,
Ja, wir müssen jetzt was killen.
Easy, easy wins, also, hier.
Wen kann ich muten?
Achso, ja das stimmt.
Das, generell ist die Soundabmischung in dem Spiel merkwürdig.
Welchen?
Ne, wir gehen, wir gehen lieber an, hm, ja doch, komm, Storch Town, blau, volle Pulle.
Ja, klar, wow, slaked, alter, slaked, krass.
Klassisches TDM gibt's, ja, das ist quasi klassisches TDM, Poggers, was zum, geil, was
ist das für eine Kacke.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, ja.
Hier, hier, drinnen, ne, auf dem Dach vielleicht?
Was?
Wow, wow, wow, wow, ich werde schon angeschneubert.
Fucker.
Hier kommt bei mir gleich was rein, Achtung, oh, das Fenster, shit, shit, shit, ah, shit.
Alter, hier ist wirklich TDM, ich leg, da ist einer bei mir, ich leg, perfekt.
Das ist wirklich TDM, Alter.
Komm, jetzt easy.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Das reicht.
So, ich hoffe, ich komme gleich wieder.
Ich habe jetzt echt einen Schuss.
Hier, lass uns zum Bus gehen.
Das war echt TDM.
Das ist ein Flowtorch.
Ah, scheiße.
Wir haben nur Kackwaffen gehabt.
Geil.
Oh, das ist gut.
Danke.
Jetzt jetzt, ja.
Ach so, ja, nimm die, nimm die, komm her.
Nimm die, nimm die.
Hier, nüchse.
Da wusste ich, dass du die nimmst.
So, ich bin wieder da.
Hier ist so eine andere.
Oh, hier ist so eine andere.
Oh, die ist nice.
Ich brauche irgendwas.
Da liegt die P90.
P90 ist top.
P90.
P90, aber die ist auch leer.
Wie das?
Ist mir egal.
60, komm.
Besser.
Du hast fast einen Top 10 Schuss geschossen.
Irgendwas.
46 Schuss.
Ah, M4.
Excellent.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Noch mal eine P90.
Gut, da sind wir jetzt ja ganz gut ausgerüstet.
Kannst jetzt ja losgehen.
Ne, passt schon.
Ich habe die P90.
Verwirrt.
Das ist das F 90 S capture.
Danke schön, easykiller.
Wir haben einen easykiller.
Haben wir noch, haben wir noch Platten irgendwo?
Ich habe...
Nochmal schade, dass man so ein Multiqu
also, dass man so ein Schwimmbad, Schwimmbad, Schwimmbad.
WOW.
Auf dem Dach von links – irgendwo, ich habe es nicht genau gesehen.
Ich sehe es nicht.
Irgendwo hinter euch.
Ich habe ihn, ich habe ihn.
Ich habe ihn.
Der kommt jetzt.
Ja, ja, warte.
Ich leg mich hin.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ist da noch mehr?
Seh ich?
Ja, hinter uns.
Hinter uns.
Oh, shit.
Hinter uns ist noch mehr.
Auf dem Dach.
Beide auf dem Dach.
MonkaS.
Ich hab fast...
Ich hab halt nix mehr.
Einer down.
Dach, Dach, Dach, Dach.
Ich hör aber noch Leute.
Ich hör noch Leute hier.
MonkaW.
Danke.
Ah, die haben Money.
Die haben Money.
Aber ansonsten haben sie nicht so viel, muss man sagen.
Ne.
Ah, wir haben ordentlich Money jetzt.
Passt.
Okay.
Äh, wir haben auch noch nicht genug Geld.
Wir müssen hier mal...
Ja, ich auch.
Genau, genau.
Lass hier mal weg.
Sag mal, Chat, kann das sein, dass der Stream ruckelt?
Boah, Sonne ist nicht so einfach zu streamen, gell?
Wollen wir direkt hochgehen?
Ja, ist ungelootet.
Ja, wir können hochgehen.
Money, Money.
Kein Ruckeln.
Ah, die Bitrate ist, glaub ich, einfach zu gering.
Ich stell gleich mal die Bitrate hoch.
Warte mal.
Kann mal kurz eine halbe Minute...
Quatsch, halbe Minute.
Zehn Sekunden aufpassen, dass ich die Bitrate hochstellen kann.
Geht schnell.
Äh, Output 7,9.
Excellent.
Die fahren weg.
Passt.
Okay.
So.
Wir können weiter drinnen, wir können hier drinnen weiter looten.
Aber lass mal unten rum reinlaufen, würde ich fast sagen.
Da liegt noch ein bisschen Geld.
Hol's dir.
Sind diese Multi-Twits, also diese Partner-Streams voll geil, wenn die dann alle untereinander fließen?
Du meinst diese Squad-Streaming-Geschichte? Ja, das ist gut.
Aber es geht nur ab Partner, sonst musst du halt über Multi-Twits machen.
Dann lass kaufen.
Hier sind noch Platten.
Was?
Beste Sniper.
Krasser Unterschied, ey. Nur 108 Frames jetzt, wenn OBS läuft.
Ja, ich auch.
Ich auch, so in dem Dreh.
Na, jetzt geht's wieder. 160, aber trotzdem.
Ja, deswegen, das meine ich ja. Ich hab immer ein bisschen Probleme.
Ich bin so Batman.
Vielleicht soll ich doch mal über GPU-Encoding machen.
Ich auch, sonst bringt nicht so viel.
Gib mal Geld, bitte.
Sieh da rin.
Boah, die kriegt er nicht.
Ist hier irgendwo was?
Mach mal Geld, Lin.
Ja, ja, ja.
Einmal.
Nimm alles, was ich hab, ey.
Ich hab ja nicht viel.
Nimm dich aus.
Hier ist nix.
Was ist hier los?
Haben die alle schon weggelootet?
Ja, ja, ja.
Das ist ja cool.
Sehr gut.
Ja, alles abgetrennt.
So muss das sein.
Das ist voll ungewohnt, wenn man 40 FPS weniger hat als sonst.
Es kommt einem fast vor, als sind 120 FPS schon gleich ruckeln.
Ich spiel eigentlich mit 200 und beim Stream hab ich 120.
Willkommen in meinem Leben, Witzel.
Die 1080p ist irgendwie noch nicht gut genug für dieses sehr gut optimierte Spiel.
Das ist doch kein Problem.
Das ist das Beste.
optimiertes spiel es geht quasi es geht quasi gar nicht besser
ach darum ach darum geht's verstehe also weil sie umso größer das spiel umso
besser
der euro truck simulator ist das doch mit irgendwie 3000 euro dlc wenn du das
das neue teil mit den bäumen spiel willst und so dann also ich sehe nichts
es kämpft alles nur ums nächste ich komme herunter gehöpft zu dir
der hochkämpfer sagt ihr seid zu leise ich stelle euch mal ein bisschen lauter
nach der runde das macht dich nicht laut hast du übersteuert wieso chat fragt ob
wir den unendlich munitions backen kennen wir den ich kenne ihn auch nicht
ich hätte auch keine schmerzen mit gerade ja
nee kenne ich nicht
kenne ich nicht
irgendwie
kann das sein dass wir außer am anfang wo tdm war keine gegner gesehen haben
aber ich weiß gar nicht wo die alle hin sind es leben noch 50 leute
da wird nichts sein
wenn hier oben ein
eine reinkunft da oben das war's komplett
wir können auch besser schießen
high octane gameplay chat ne
ja das ist halt unlukor ich weiß nicht wo die gegner sind was ist
ich bin hier hoch
was
perfekt
ja echt ist
ja
du musst auf die telefonzelle springen und dann auf diese schräge und dann
die telefonzelle diese telefonzelle mit den stinkenden fliegen und alles
ach was ist das für eine akkinozie
höh das ist der direkt
ja da braucht man einen hauch zum rufen
haha
ja so
ich seh schon gleich wer die umsnipe oder irgendwas
dem ich auch nicht glaube ich geh jetzt ohne schiess
ja
oh sag bloß da gibt es gegner
ja so
exzellent
ich lass mal jetzt obenrum das clear machen sonst kommen die nachher von oben runter und wir haben
jetzt sind wieder die königlichen camper die alles zugelassen haben
kleine box gedudelt haben
das wär doch witzig
äh wir haben auch kein geld also so ein paar uavs und so wären schon nicht schlecht bevor wir da reingehen
aber hier ist gelootet
aber hier oben ist doch eine kiste
ne das ist auch schon unten
wo sind denn die
ich seh niemand
ich glaub die sind da hinten nur so bei roche
wir haben die anti stream sniper die rennen alle irgendwohin rum
die rennen weg
haha die rennen weg
oh nein der dk kommt
Warte mal, warte mal, war da was?
Ne.
Wenn du das grüne Laser bist, bin ich.
Grüne Laser bin auch ich, aber ich hab nur Taktlaser.
Hä?
Kann doch nicht sein, dass wir ins Dritte von der Map kommen.
Ja, wo sind die alle?
What the fuck?
Dieses Haus hier und sowas, da könnten vielleicht welche schimmeln, wenn die richtig campen.
Ja, echt hart.
Man kommt auch von unten wieder runter.
Also so wenig Gegner hab ich ja selten gesehen.
Aber wir sind halt unten am Samm auch safe, gell?
Ne, ne, ich würde halt gerne bleiben auf jeden Fall.
Aber wenn du da oben jetzt in die Wälder reinläufst, kriegst du da die halbe Militärin.
Also hier sind Scheiben kaputt an den Fenstern, hier war auf jeden Fall schon was.
Ne, hier ist auch nix mehr.
Ah, hier ist einer bei mir im Haus, bei mir im Haus.
Unten, unten, unten.
Hier in der Ecke.
Hier in der Ecke war er.
Excellent, kommt mal zurück.
Oh, von hinten auch, fuck.
Perfekt, excellent.
Na toll.
Ah, fuck, Alter.
Ey, so ein Rumgesitze wieder.
Oh man.
Huge, genau.
Jetzt gibt's huge Gulag-Win.
Und dann...
Einfach niemand im Gulag.
Oh.
Ich mach euch mal n' Ticken lauter.
Ah.
Der Drop kommt so lange nicht.
Da sind zwei Helis, ich glaub die spawnen da.
Kappa.
Ja, was willst du, was kannst du jetzt großartig machen?
Es gibt grad gar nichts zu tun.
Es gibt nicht mal mehr nen Suchauftrag, wo man richtig reden kann.
Mach die weg, die uns geholt haben.
Alter, was hocken die denn da schon wieder den ganzen Tag rum?
Die waren da das ganze Spiel schon.
Oh Gott.
Die haben sich nicht bewegt, glaub ich.
Die hatten...
Der eine hat nen Standard-M4 gehabt, also...
Ich glaub...
Ne, ne, der...
Der eine hatte so ne richtig schlechte...
...Plassen-M4.
Da war ja aber alles unge...
Es gibt ja noch nicht mal nen Drop hier, ist ja nichts.
Ja, es gibt echt nichts.
Da wär noch n' Sicherungsauftrag, aber...
Ja, aber...
Ja.
Mach den Kopfgeldauftrag, easy.
Ja, aber das ist ja nicht, äh...
Jetzt haben sie natürlich gutes Equipment.
Ja, n...
Nimm die Hops oder so, keine Ahnung.
Jetzt hockt da auch noch jemand drin, pass auf.
So.
Das ist ja nichts, Camper.
Die Kisten zulassen.
Hä, ich hab sie nicht getroffen.
Oh, du...
Was ist denn das nun?
Wie krass das vercampt ist gerade, was geht da ab?
Das ist aber schlecht.
Ich hör sie, ich hör sie rumrennen.
Ich auch, aber bringt halt nichts.
Wenn ich da jetzt weiterlaufe, dann sehen die mich aus dem Fenster.
Wenn ich da weiterlaufe...
Das ist so maximal gut gemacht von denen.
Das ist maximal...
Ehrenhaft.
Äh, ehrenhaft.
Also, in welcher Welt...
Kisten, Kisten zulassen, um zu baiten.
Das ist so krank...
5.000 Sekunden.
Die holen auch noch ihren Maiden?
Die holen ihren Maiden?
Wisst ihr...
Da kommt er.
Target right here.
Der hat mich nicht gesehen.
Ne, der kommt doch überhaupt nicht hier.
Der ist Brain Afka.
Hammer.
Das hast du gebraucht.
Ich muss da jetzt halt irgendwie weg...
Oh, nein!
Sieht er mich?
Ah, was soll's.
Ah...
Oh, Matrix.
Neo-Styler.
Also, die haben wirklich die ganze Runde...
Nichts anderes gemacht, ey.
Nichts anderes, als da gesessen.
Heftig.
Also, so eine Runde hatten wir lange nicht.
Am Anfang TDM, dann nichts.
Und dann am Arsch der Welt rumgecampt, Alter.
HugoV, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub.
Wer ist neu hier?
RealNicolai.
Moin.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
EasyKiller, auch wieder acht Monate am Start.
Ah, ja, ja.
Das Audio ist nicht nur merkwürdig, sondern Crap, ja.
Also, das Modern Warfare-Audio ist echt Hardcore-Fail.
Richtig viel Spatman.
Aber egal.
Nächste Runde.
Wenn wir nicht mehr nötig haben, in Häuser reinzugehen,
dass wir es lassen, vielleicht, wenn der Zögel...
Ja, du brauchst...
Ja, du hast schon recht, aber irgendwo...
Ich meine, wir hatten ja auch nichts an Killstreaks oder sonst was.
Ne, ja, stimmt.
Ganz ohne UAVs zu gewinnen
und Zeug ist halt auch nicht so das Ding.
Es war aber eine sehr merkwürdige Runde.
F.
Muss man noch pressen.
Das ist doch das neue Meta.
Als wenn es ins Vitamin lädt.
Hier, hier.
Nahe gekampft.
Wo ist er hin?
Wow.
Hey, hey.
Ich will hier nahe kampfen.
Wie viel zu so hast du?
Ich habe vorher 75 gesehen oder so.
Äh, 76 gerade.
Hammer.
Ey.
Ich habe nur Faust.
Ich habe nur Faust und Gnade.
So, wir können uns jetzt ja schon mal überlegen.
Das fliegt ziemlich gut.
Also, wenn das wirklich genau so über die Mitte...
Das fliegt immer gut für Stolz.
Ja, ist auch.
Das fliegt echt immer gut.
Deswegen ist Stolz von der besten Truppe.
Stolz-Town top.
Die ganzen World Record High-Skill-Gameplays, die gehen ja alle eins nebendran, ne?
Super-Store, wo du gerade die Faust nicht...
Aber Super-Store geht auch klar, wenn deine Gegner keine Hände haben.
Äh, ich passe nach der Runde den Sound nicht.
Das ist nicht so einfach, weil das Game ja sonst zu laut wird, wenn ich das insgesamt
lauter mache.
Aber...
Kannst du ja...
Kannst du ja einfach das Game an sich leise machen.
Ja, ja, habe ich schon.
Habe ich schon auf 14.
Das ist, ähm...
Ja, ja, das ist ein bisschen Fail.
Ich könnte ingame das Game lauter machen.
Aber...
Vorne ist einer. Ein Gelb.
Schwimmbad, Schwimmbad. Zwei Stück.
Ja, ja.
Ich geh auch auf die andere Seite rauf.
Oben auf dem Schwimmbad.
Auf dem Schwimmbad oben einer.
Wow, oh, oh, fuck.
Ey, hier ist wieder TDM angesagt.
Ah, da ist noch eine Kiste. Ich hol die.
Ich muss hier auch mal weg.
Wir brauchen ein paar Platten.
Juhu, da ist endlich eine Palt drin.
Die brauch ich.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Das nächste kommt direkt in die Ecke.
Oh, fuck.
Ich hab nicht mal viel Muni.
Jetzt kommt die Shotgun raus
und die werden jetzt geowen.
Die sind hier im Haus drin.
Ich kann denen nicht helfen.
Ich weiß.
Ich bin hier hinter der...
Nein!
Fuck, Alter.
Hätte klappen können.
Es ist nur noch einer gewesen.
Nur noch einer gewesen.
Da, wo ich gestorben bin. In dem grünen Zelt.
Hat jemand mit Schild?
Hast du einen Schild?
Der hat einen Schild.
Jetzt wird hier richtig reingerusht.
Einer P, einer P.
Ich hab nichts hier.
Was zum Geier? Wo ist der?
Ich bin das.
Da kommt ein Schild.
Will er mich verarschen?
Dreckige...
Ich sag's nicht.
Moment, Moment.
Wer kommt?
Bleib am Leben.
So, easy win.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Es ist da einer in Gelb bei euch.
Also, okay, vielleicht ist es der, der gestorben ist.
Von da hat es gerade geschossen zumindest.
Äh...
P90.
Ja, das ist die. Die hatte ich eben.
Kann ich empfehlen.
Die hatte ich eben, um die zu killen, glaube ich.
Ich hab ihnen einen Schild getroffen.
Sein Schild wird gebrannt.
Äh... Herze, was jetzt?
Habt ihr noch einen getötet danach?
Weil ich hab nur drei...
Okay, ich glaub...
Aber das hat noch einen...
Dann lass hier mal weg.
Oder haben wir genug zum kaufen?
Ich kaufe uns Platten.
Das hätte gerade, glaube ich, gereicht, dass wir Koffer aufkönnen.
Ja, aber erst mal überleben.
Dann lass mal wieder Richtung Flucht.
Ja, das ist gut, weil wir kommen auf Kisten und hier liegt noch Zeug auf dem Weg.
Kisten und hier auch noch ne Kiste. Nehmt alles mit.
Ja, lass die oben, die haben Geld gesammelt für uns. Das ist ok.
Ah, Money, Money, Money.
Enemy kommt.
Hat's enemy dropping over the AO?
Ich seh nix.
Die sind bei dem Zeitlager.
Aber die haben Zeug schon wieder geklirt.
Bei mir, über mir.
Nee.
Was? What?
Was zum...
Ich glaub's net.
Ich glaub's net, Alter.
Was zum...
Alter Kacke.
Oh, ich hab voll vorbeigeknallt, ey.
Ah, shit.
Huge NA.
Oh, das war verkackt, Alter.
Direkt da, ich kann nichts machen, ich kann dich nicht ansagen.
Ich steh hier rein.
Wenn du willst, ich steh hier rein, ich hab ein Schild.
Ich kann dich decken.
Komm rein zu mir.
Der brennt.
Wie, der brennt?
Ich hab's gerade nicht mal bekommen.
Der brennt.
Nice, danke.
Hat der ja keine Millisekunde gedauert.
Nee, echt nicht.
Are you not entertained?
Hier liegt er noch.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, Alter.
Ich prob irgendwas mit Range.
Da oben rinnt auch noch einer runter.
Können wir den Plan mit dem Airport jetzt mal durchziehen?
Ja, bitte.
Ja, weg hier.
I obtain gameplay.
Was ist das eigentlich für eine Crap-Waffe hier?
Ist das eine Auke?
Auke ist richtig gut.
Find ich.
Aber ich glaub, da oben sind Gegner drauf.
Wir können auch Sieghauses tun, aber wir haben kein Geld.
Wir müssten eigentlich auch mal looten gehen am Bahn...
Ich wollt grad sagen, am Bahnhof, am Flughafen.
Fuck, ich geh zu einer Platte, komm.
Hier.
Noch einer, aber egal.
Heiß.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wir kommen aus dem Airport raus.
Ich geh mit Schild vor.
Von wo?
Von links oder?
Hier.
Einer da oben.
Ich geh mal mit Schild.
Ich kann mit Schild reingucken.
Unten.
Unten auf dem Weg ist einer.
Ein Gelb auf dem Weg war einer.
Gelb auf dem Weg...
Achso, unten.
Unten, unten, unten.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass der hier unten gleich reingestellt ist.
Kommt.
Ich kann mit Schild drunter gehen und gucken.
Geht's nicht?
Wir haben genug Geld für den Drop.
Wir können auch...
Ah, haben wir nicht.
200 fehlen.
Ja, dann looten wir hier mal durch.
Der ist aber noch, gell?
Irgendwo ist hier einer.
Ja, ja.
Da müssen wir ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ja, die Kerl kann überliegen, Mann.
Boah.
Ist eklig auf der Airport innen drin.
Kommt ein Auto.
Du musst bitte hingehen, vielleicht.
Ja, das ist echt...
Du darfst Richtung Drop gehen.
Du darfst einfach rausgehen.
Scheiß drauf.
Richtung Drop und dann hoch wieder zum Damm.
Was...
Wieso...
Ach, da rennt was.
Ich seh die.
Ach, Mann.
Das...
Ja, dann wird's da echt paranoid.
Ach, ne.
Hier geht's einfach nicht.
Also, wie gesagt, der eine ist auf jeden Fall noch irgendwo hinter uns.
Ja.
Okay, erstmal loot.
Die, die mit ihrem Auto da gekommen sind, die hatten auch irgendeine Mission.
Ähm, wir könnten uns jetzt auch direkt schon mal hoch Richtung Damm hin tun, weil da
kommen die jetzt diesmal eh...
Uns fehlen noch ein Geldpatzen zum Drop.
Ne, wir sind ja ganz gut ausgestattet.
Das stimmt eigentlich auch wieder.
Das passt schon.
Wir sollten jetzt lieber vielleicht noch ein erster in die Revue gehen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Da wird schon keine Klemo liegen.
Geh doch nicht hoch da.
Ich kann hier auch in dieses Haus hier gehen, wo ich bin.
Noch mehr Geld.
Ich hab oben die Cash.
Die haben gekauft irgendwas.
Die haben den Matt gekauft oder so.
Der kauft jetzt so ein Airpods.
Der ist ja direkt am Drop.
Ich hab hier die Sniper-Money.
Ich hab halt nur AR dabei, ne?
Brauchst du Sniper-Money?
Ne, ne, da ist Sniper-Money.
Achso.
Die sind in ihrem Drop.
Das sind die mit den Autos.
Die müssen eigentlich gleich crossen.
Guck mal, rechts von uns, da war auch irgendwas.
Hinter uns ist auch viel.
Ja, ich hab...
Ich stell mich mit dem Schild und recruit einfach rüber.
Das geht doch, oder?
Ich guck mal, ob hinten irgendwas anrückt.
Da unten.
Ihr macht das schon.
Die schießen, glaube ich, auf den, der sich da von uns versteckt hat, so ein bisschen.
Ja, ich glaub's auch.
Alter, Leute, guckt euch mal den Flughafen an, ey.
Das ist ja...
Huge Detail.
Hier, ich nehm mal die Sniper.
Ich nehm das Schild gleich wieder mit.
Geht nicht.
So, ich leg mich jetzt mal hin.
Ich kann von hier oben eh nix machen.
Wir müssen weitergehen Richtung Damm, würde ich sagen.
Ja, wir können jetzt...
Waren wir da, wenn es wird, zu warten, bis die...
...bis die zu uns crossen müssen, die wegmachen?
Helfen den Einsturmsaugern?
Dauert aber noch zwei Minuten.
Will...
Über meinem Auto.
Hier an der Kaufi, an der Kaufi ist jemand neben uns.
Die, die ich markiert hab.
Ja, dann lass sie nach rechts gehen oder so, zu dem Auto.
Lass das Auto nehmen, lass das Auto geradeaus nehmen.
Ich bin dafür.
Die Fenster von den Neusen sind kaputt, Achtung.
Hier hockt's bestimmt wieder drin, ich sag's euch.
C4 dran, private C4-Kontrolle.
Nein, warte, ich hab geklückt.
Komm rein.
Gleich kommt ein RPG oder irgendwas.
Ist das die Kaufi, die ich gerade markiert hab?
Ja, genau, da war ein WG.
Ja, ja.
Da war auf jeden Fall was.
Alter, ich bin gleich...
Ich bin gleich...
Nein, nein, nein.
Alles gut.
Die sind da oben auf dem Berg.
MonkaS.
Oh mein Gott, oh mein Gott.
Okay, wer hat noch Platten übrig?
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall aus dem Auto raus.
Kannst du mir mal was droppen?
Die haben mich richtig hart getroffen, ne?
Danke.
Aber reicht das?
Warte, ich kann die auch noch mitnehmen.
Ja, besser, besser als nix.
Lass die richtig nirgends.
Ich geb dir noch eine.
Hier.
Alter, wie...
Was zum...
Geier.
Komm nämlich hier nicht hin.
What the fuck?
Wie funktioniert das?
Ja, du musst...
Du musst deinen Schnellsprint machen.
So, jetzt.
Du musst da hoch.
Exzellent.
In einer Sekunde.
Hüpf auf das Klohäuschen drauf.
Hinter dir.
Und dann?
Hüpf.
Da hoch.
Und jetzt wirst du warten.
Und dann diesen schnellen Sprint.
Wie ist das?
Wie soll das...
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Ja, ja.
Ist mir schon klar.
Ah, okay.
Okay.
Verstanden.
Hier kommt man nur hier rum hoch.
Andersrum geht's nicht.
Sicher.
Ja.
Außer mit dem Auto von der anderen Seite.
Aber das machen die nicht.
Aber wo sind die?
Huck mal da unten auf die Straße.
Hier.
Siehst du was?
Ja, einen hab ich gesehen.
Ah ja, da.
Links, links.
Achtung.
Oh Gott.
An...
An gelb.
Wo?
Ich stell mich da vor mit Schild.
Wo sind die aber hier?
Vergessen.
Egal.
Der eine probiert hier irgendwie hochzukommen, ne?
Der ist dann Richtung hier gelaufen.
Hier.
Ja.
Müssen wir ein bisschen abchecken.
Nicht, dass der es schafft.
Ja, ja.
Der schafft es nicht.
Der kann nicht so hoch.
Da ist noch ein Gegner.
Blau und rot sind die Gegner.
Äh, klar ist das nicht.
Das ist jetzt schlecht.
Die können jetzt voll reinballern hier.
Exz...
Excellent strats.
Warum trennen denn die Zonen immer so Müll?
Einmal gerade.
Dann lass doch...
Lass doch.
Ja gut.
Die müssen auf jeden Fall jetzt zu uns...
Durch den Tunnel durch.
Ja.
Unten.
Wir können die also im Tunnel echt abcampen.
40 Meter da unten schon.
Ah, ich hab einen gedownt von denen.
Bei dem Verkehrsschild bei Orange.
Okay.
49 Meter unten am Tunnel ist einer.
Jo.
Gucken wir mal, ob das denn nicht beleuchtet.
Der ist da vorne.
Der schüttelt schon hoch.
26 Meter.
Der ist da unten irgendwo.
Ja.
Rechts irgendwo ist er.
Der versucht glaube ich hochzukommen, ne?
Ja.
Dann verhindert das...
Ja, ja klar.
Geht irgendwie.
Fehlt aber noch.
Fehlt.
13 Meter.
Ja, der müsste da sein.
Der ist genau hier.
Der ist da nicht.
Der ist wahrscheinlich noch im Tunnel drin.
Ja, der wird zurück nicht geholt.
Der ist im Tunnel drin.
Ja.
Ah, da unten rechts.
Einer Pferde.
Pass mal auf den unten im Tunnel auf.
Ja, wir müssen gucken.
Das sind ja bestimmt noch mehr.
40 Meter.
Ich glaub, der ist weggehüpft, oder?
Also ich hab ja einen von denen gedownt.
Ah, da unten.
Der müsste gleich im Glasshop stehen.
Wenn der es nicht macht, dann bestimmt irgendwas hin.
Hast du ihn?
Ja.
Nice.
Oh.
Von unten schießt noch was hoch.
Jemand SMG-Munition?
Ja, ich kann ja ein bisschen was trocken.
Spielt jemand SMG sonst?
Ja, ich hab MP5.
Nee, nicht spielen.
Spiel die, mach.
Nee, die liebt mir.
Der spielt nicht.
Tu mal nicht das.
Alter, das Game ruckelt voll, wenn OBS an ist.
Was ist das für ein Crap?
Ja, das meinte ich ja.
Ja, ich hab ja noch nicht...
Gerade Warzone ruckelt.
Normaler MP geht.
Sollen wir eigentlich...
So richtig shoot...
Hast du mir die Muni?
Ja, die liegt da.
Wo?
Die liegt da mitten im Feld.
Blödweg.
Ja.
Kannst du die mal markieren?
Oder sagen wo?
Ich seh's nicht.
Weil die ist...
Wo gaut er?
Ah, da.
Ich hab 6, 5...
Wenn wir ohne den kommen, gehen wir hoch, gell?
Also, die, die anderen drei, die uns da hinten angegriffen haben, die sind, die sind ja auch
noch da, ne?
Also, die sind da nicht irgendwie weg.
Also, die...
Ja, die sind da nicht am Damm, oder?
Sind die nicht am Damm?
Von unten kamen gerade Schüsse, ja?
Es kann durchaus sein, dass die mittlerweile unten sind.
Ja, du kommst eigentlich nur über einen Sneaky-Weg.
Gehen wir hoch.
Ja, du kommst nur über einen Sneaky-Weg.
Aber lass mich kurz den Tunnel noch abkrempen mit der Zone.
Vielleicht kann die rein.
Ach, du meinst, dass die über die Pool R war?
Das schaffen die niemals.
Guck mal, ob die hier den Tunnel abkrempen.
Also, ob die da durchkommen.
Da ist nichts drin.
Ne, ne, ne, da ist nichts.
Ich kann reingucken und die Zone kommt gerade.
Das ist so...
Geil, du kommst hier halt nie wieder hoch, wenn du einmal nicht über den linken Polizeistationen
deinen Weg gemacht hast.
Außer über diese Sneaky-Straße da rechts oben.
An der Wand hochglitschen.
So, wie sieht es denn hier aus?
Oh, ein Schildgeschütz hier oben.
Toll.
Ich sehe mal wieder ein Nichts, ne?
Hier ist noch ungelootet.
Ne.
Ah, ne, nicht ungelootet, aber...
Nicht ungelootet.
Ne.
Soll ich mal in der UAV rausfahren?
Ja.
Wenn du hast, ja.
Weiß nicht.
Doch, doch, ist nicht verkehrt.
An Blau ist einer, unten an der Kaufe ist einer und an Grün einer.
Ja.
Wollen wir mit...
Komm, ich komme...
Soll ich mit dem LKW...
Komm.
Ne, ne.
Ne.
Oh, guck mal.
Wo kommen sie denn die her?
Da kommen so drei so...
Da hinten, da hinten.
Da hinten.
Ich sehe nichts.
Ach, da.
What the hell?
Ja, die sind da hinten.
Was machen die da?
Hallo?
Der holt ihn hoch, der holt ihn hoch.
Soll ich die holen?
Ja.
Ich habe was richtig dummes gemacht.
Aber ich finde es geil.
Ich gehe jetzt hier oben aufs Dach und baller da runter.
Habt ihr ungefähr eine Ahnung, wo genau sie sind?
Warum?
Ja.
Weil die mich einfach auf dem Feld abschießen.
Wo denn?
Kannst du die mal...
Unter dir am Stein.
Achso.
Aber blau oder was?
Ne.
Gegen links an der Ecke jetzt.
Ja.
Oh mein Gott!
Moritz, sieele dir mal ein kleines However...
Oh mein Gott, Moritz.
tomb voucher!
War das Auto da runter?
Wir sind doch unter dir!
Da sind sie doch!
Jetzt aussteigen!
Nein!
Wir machen es nur!
Team Vyped.
Locker الأ assigned
Ja!
Schöne Welt.
Er sagt ich zugrunde.
Boden!
Oh man ey.
Ich kann nicht.
Hat der irgend was sinnvolles dabei?
Ja.
Nicht drauf?
Habe ich selbst.
So lass mal hier weg.
eh, lass mich mal in die Zone laufen.
du nicht das Auto mitnehmen?
Call of Duty Steine kann man hier hoch bestimmt nicht, oder?
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Battlefield 3 mit dem rumgestelltes hier über die Steine.
Das auch nicht richtig funktioniert.
Hoch!
Null.
Die Zone ist sehr gut für uns, aber...
Bist du dir sicher, dass sie im Haus sind?
Da waren vorher die roten Punkte.
Ich guck mal, ich guck mal, Hardspeed.
Nix da.
Aber das heißt nichts bei den Campern.
Ja, ne, das heißt echt nichts. Kommt man hier hoch? Ne, oder?
Das ist zu... Call of Duty Steine.
Wir müssen mit in die Zone hinten rum, dann schaffen wir es vielleicht.
Also hier hatten wir absolut keine Deckung, das heißt wir müssen uns hier die Deckung holen.
Hier hat's gute Steine für Deckung.
Ah, hier kommt man wenigstens vorbei.
Da schießt einer am Boden.
Also falls die echt noch in dem Haus drin sind, müssen wir gucken von hinten.
Ja, hier sind wir jetzt drin mit blau.
Gut, wir können aber jetzt noch kurz gucken.
Oh, da schießt einer was.
Sind nur noch 18 Gegner.
Also krass, das rumgecampt ist da. Wahnsinn hier gerade.
Wann denn? Waren die anderen Spiele was? Nicht so fast.
Wird so, ja, das geht schon klar.
Ist echt nicht normal.
Wollen uns halt am besten nicht sehen.
Wenn's unten schießt...
Echt da?
Ja.
Noch weiter, noch weiter hinten.
Da glaub ich.
Ich hab's nur ganz, ganz leise gehört.
Also an Sounds, aber warte mal.
Ja, irgendwo.
Die Zone kommt so langsam, wir können echt mit der Zone rein, weil wir sind ein...
Ja.
Ich geh mal zu Max.
Ne, ne, ich komm, ich komm auch hinter, falls irgendwas von hinten auch reingelaufen kommt.
Ich hör nicht, dass sich einer zwischen euch reinmacht.
Ja.
Ne, von da kann nix mehr kommen.
Wir haben hier eine richtig gute Kurzprosi, um zu gucken, wo die Gegner sind, aber alt für mehr auch nicht.
Hier hoch müssen wir vielleicht.
Lass erst mal gucken, wo noch was kommt.
Das ist richtig Krieg.
Da wird richtig geballert.
Zone, komm her. Komm her, Zone.
Oh, holy hell.
Wir haben aber den, wir haben den Highground noch.
Lass mal hier oben.
Ey.
Wir müssen so oben reingehen, dann haben wir eigentlich von hinten nichts mehr zu befürchten.
Aber ihr lauft dann genau auf dieses eine Haus.
Ihr habt dann, wenn ihr rechts rum geht, seid ihr lost.
Ihr könnt nichts machen, wenn ihr rechts rum geht.
Ja, ich will nur schädlieren.
Die Zone drückt euch in ein Haus rein, wo Gegner drin sind.
Ah, hier ist ein Gegner, hier ist ein Gegner.
Ich schieß drauf.
Einer, einer P, einer P.
Ja, ich seh, ich seh, ich weiß.
Äh, what the hell.
Sterben.
Random.
Keine Ahnung, wie schnell er mich umgenietet hat, Alter.
WTF.
Ist der Stream leise?
Echt, Leute, ist der Stream leise?
Der Kerl hat mich einfach komplett, äh, weggestellt.
Ah, die Leute sind leise.
Ja, okay, das...
Dann stell ich jetzt mal kurz Sound ein.
Wie macht man das jetzt am besten?
Ah.
Ah, wie schnell der Typ mich eben wegges...
Ah, wie...
Es war echt krass.
Echt krass, wie schnell er mich eben weggestellt hat, der Typ.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
So, ich muss mal kurz...
So, machen wir mal das Game ein bisschen leiser.
TS ein bisschen lauter.
Gucken wir mal, ob das besser funktioniert jetzt.
Hab den rechts nicht erwartet.
Und Luko.
Ich glaub, jetzt ist besser.
Hoffe ich mal.
Klar carryen lassen, was sonst?
Das ist ein Teamspiel.
Fuck, jetzt ist es wieder warm, Alter.
Ich treff da irgendwie keine gute Balance.
Eieiei.
Und sonst so.
Also Sound-Settings sind wirklich ziemlich, ziemlich kacke einzustellen.
Weil ihr seid bei mir jetzt viel zu laut.
Easy Win, ne?
Ja.
Easy Win, war das echt...
Dann machen wir jetzt hier lauter.
So, ist besser.
Und das Game wird leiser gemacht.
So machen wir das.
Jetzt müsste es besser funktionieren.
Ich hab einfach mein Laptop nebenan an der Hand für mein Stream-Desk.
Und seitdem hab ich noch weniger Lust.
So, ich glaub, Leute, Chat, ich glaub, jetzt ist die Lautstärke besser, ne?
Flamehaze, was meinst du?
An Spielern?
Nee, nicht so wirklich.
Ich spiel ja gar nicht so oft.
Aber ich muss sagen, es macht doch mehr Bock, als ich gedacht hätte.
Im Garten.
Ja, das ist ein Fischteich.
Aber ich hab mich zu sehr drauf verlassen, dass ihr da mitkommt.
Oder dass ihr da früher da seid.
Weil ich über Open Field den...
Der eine hat den revived.
Und ich dachte, es reicht, bis zu dem Felsen zu crashen.
Bis der in den Ofen rum hat.
Ja, da hast du gemacht was Dummes.
Da musst du sagen, wo wir hinmüssen.
Nee, es war ja schon...
Ja, es war ja schon...
Absolut dumm.
Also, ich wusste ja, dass es dumm war.
Aber es war halt 50-50 Gamble.
Ob es reicht, da rüber zu crossen, bis der in den Ofen kommt.
Aber es hat halt auf zwei Meter nicht gereicht.
Oder so.
So, jetzt hoffe ich, dass die Sound-Settings passen, ja.
Hey.
Actually, ein bisschen bitter.
So.
Let's go, schreib ich in ein Chat.
Dann mach ich ihn wieder zu.
Ja.
Leute findest du hier eigentlich?
Teamspeak5 ist dieser Discord-Klon.
Achso, ja. Okay, stimmt. Danke.
Hab ich vergessen.
Der irgendwie
keine Abnehmer finden wird,
glaube ich. Ja, der ist
noch nicht live. Der sollte
doch schon rauskommen vor einem Jahr
oder so. Die Betas, die Close-Beta
glaube ich noch.
Close-Beta für einen.
Voice-Chat. Ich weiß auch nicht,
was mit denen los ist.
Oh mein Gott.
Ja, gleich clean.
Wollte ich nicht beschweren.
Ich hab meine Hand-Karpette im Bild.
Ich höre euch irgendwie doppelt gerade.
Ah.
Machst weg, oh sorry.
Hier ist nix.
Nix gelandet, glaube ich.
Oho.
Ich hab ein UAV
am Start.
Der wird eh gekillt.
Ja, wir kriegen bestimmt gleich 400.
Oder was kriegen wir denn dafür?
Ja, wenn der am Schuh-Bus dort gleich
down geht.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein Viertel eher, oder?
Jetzt ist das Game viel zu leise.
Kann man das Game
ein bisschen lauter stellen?
Okay, Money, Money,
Plates, perfekt.
Wir können doch fast
kaufen.
Ja, aber Vierer kann man so viel schneller
kaufen, ist doch gut.
Das Game meint es gut mir heute mit Loot.
Was ich aber nicht verstehe,
dass du beim Duo genauso viel Geld
brauchst.
Bei Solo brauchst du auch 10,
aber die haben doch da die Drop
irgendwie hochgeschraubt,
dass du mehr Geld getroffen
bekommst.
Das wäre klug, das hätten die doch sicherlich nicht gemacht.
Bei Solo hast du...
Junge, voll der Hate gegen dieses
arme Spiel.
Verdient.
8000, direkt der Drop, fast
wie bei Plander.
Mein ganzes Geld liegt an Kiste.
Okay, ich nehm... wie viel hat der für Cash?
Kann dir was geben, oder? Habt ihr genug für einen Drop?
Reicht schon, reicht schon, also zu zweit nicht.
3,7, bitte.
Ah, reicht nicht. Hier, jetzt.
Wie kippst du wieder
Cent mit aus?
Naja, immer, da wird immer nur abgezählt.
Aber ist in Zeiten der Rezession halt auch verständlich.
Präzision
Jawohl
Ah Platten
Pogos
Pogos Platte
Powerplatte
Der wusste schon als das Spiel raus kam
Predicted
Okay wo ist doch unser Bounty Target
Oh Superstore
Nee das kommt zu Tanke
Tanke Tanke
Ja wir brauchen aber neue
Ja das reicht nicht
Oder ich mach einen richtig krassen Shot
Ne ich seh die nicht mehr
Alles vorbei
Ich flieg auch hinterher jetzt
Volle Pulle
Wir haben 8 Sekunden
Easy
Das Ding ist wie ein Gears Cockpit und wie uns
Der war total ausgenutzt deswegen haben wir ihn auf Verzweck
Oben drauf schneidet einer 8
Aus dem Fenster
Oh Shit
Hinter uns kommen Teams
Achtung Achtung Achtung
Superstopp Superstopp
Lass die mal zurück bis dort rein
Lass die killen Lass die killen
Ich glaub oben im Fenster im Haus war glaub einer
Oben drin
Excellent habt ihr getroffen C4
Ja
Hit Hit Hit
Down Down Down
Aber der wär nicht tot einer stand noch drin
Was zum Teufel von wo
Vom Dach
Ich seh nix
Ich seh Superstore auch nix
Ja die waren voll Superstore
Hey hier hier ist einer unter uns
Okay
Okay ich geh mal raus
Ich seh ihn ja
Ja ich seh ihn
Hat gut Hit
Ist hinter dem Felsen
Ja die stehen alle
What the hell
Eins
Guck mal
Die campen hier aber zu dritt drauf
Da ist ein ganzes Team das oben drauf steht
Guck mal
Mo guck mal da zu
Oh mein Gott
Die sind alle aufgeschützt
Alle aufgeschützt
Ja ja ja
Absolut weg
Lass wieder weg
Lass da weg
Ja ja
Der liegt da noch ausgenutzt ne
Oder habt ihr den nicht gefinisht
Ich seh den gar nicht
Irgendwo am Felsen ne
Hier kommt einer
Woa
Einer ausgenockt hier hinten
Ich hab den einen geholt
Oh einer ist tot
Alles gut
Ja ja ich hol dich
Ich hol dich
Aber ich brauch unbedingt Platten
Kaufstation
Obwohl wir sind auch bisschen arm
Aber nicht
Obwohl wir nicht ganz
Da Team
Vorne vorne vorne
Vorm Haus
Rennst du Koffie
Ja ja Koffie
Ich mach ULV
ja vorm haus okay ich habe gut überlebt pass pass pass
wo seien ja eine ziemlich gesplittert sind jetzt eigentlich tot bei euch da
am store oder wo wir eben
was zum teufel ist gar nicht wo ich hin soll bringe mir was mit ich gucke ob es
irgendwo was gibt
ist nix
hier gibt es null alle sollten erst mal unsere leute helfen
ja ok jetzt auch noch scheiß schott kann egal dass man das jetzt mal hin zu
unseren leuten irgendwie wenn es geht
wo wiran
und z patterns und der wcur vor gutschaft
rot GET OUT ALL PEOPLE
ja ich bin da
das war k Bahnweg
ja ja OCK
mit einer tout sonne
der dort unten
hier geht es gar nicht rein
kommen
erstmals elf gehen
da kann man nur wieder nicht durch springen
like
über
하 da kann man nur wieder nicht durch springen
Ha da kann man immer wieder nicht durch springen
Dutch
Come on
Ich habe die mega aufgehalten dadurch.
Ich brauche noch irgendeine halbwegs sinnvolle Waffe.
Ja, ich komme gleich runter vom Dach drauf gehüpft.
Lass erstmal bitte von hier oben nochmal gucken.
Die kommen jetzt von hinten.
Da kommen einige, glaube ich.
Ja, ich stelle meinen Zielturret oben hin.
Auf YOLO-Basis.
Auf dem Laden ist hier, glaube ich, besser.
Wie kommt man denn hier hoch eigentlich?
Die kommen jetzt rechts von der Straße.
Okay, ich habe sie.
Wer war der Falsche?
Da sind sie.
Da hinten, ich sehe sie.
Einer geht auf den Bus.
Perfekt.
Ich sehe Fernrohre.
Ich habe noch nie dieses Zielturret genutzt.
Aber das ist gute Second-Control.
Einer Shield-Break.
Hinter dem Heuballen.
Wie komme ich zu dir hoch?
Hinter gelb ist einer.
Die sind auf dem roten Dach, wo ihr vorhin drauf wart.
Ohne Ende haben die.
Max, komm nach rechts.
Ja, ja, ja, okay.
Rechts davon noch Max.
Da hinten, da hinten ist er drin.
Keine Muni mehr.
Ja, wundern wir nicht.
Komm mit.
Ich habe aber noch hier.
Ich sehe einen Loot-Laden nach oben.
Ja, kann ich da hin?
Ich komme mit, ich komme mit.
Ich habe noch 13k.
Sind die hier noch?
Die müssen da noch sein.
Egal, ich probiere es.
Lass mal oben noch einen Drop kaufen.
Hier sind Gegner.
Oh mein Gott, die sind ja bei mir.
Egal.
Das waren die gleichen.
44 Meter, geradeaus, zwei Leute.
Ich sehe es.
38, die sind oben drauf.
Rechts rum, ja.
Oben, oben.
Lass mal links laufen.
Ich gehe hier hoch.
Oben drauf ist vorhin eine Koffie-Zone.
Ja, ja, die werden das kaufen.
Max, ich komme.
Ich habe einen genockt, wir finishen.
Ich komme, ich komme, ich komme.
Einer auf einer P, alles gut.
Okay, ich komme, ich komme.
Einer auf einer P.
Links, links.
Da hinten ist einer auf einer P.
Wieder ausgenockt.
Geht auf.
Alter.
What?
Weg, weggesniped.
Nice, sehr gut.
Perfekt.
Einfach in your face gesniped.
Wir sind am Arsch der Welt gespawnt.
Egal.
Ich dachte, wir haben nur zwei Minuten noch.
Ich habe nicht drauf geachtet.
Egal.
Wir holen es.
Kommen wir.
Wir können das jetzt noch weiter aufmachen.
Ja.
Aha.
Das ist das einzigste, was ich jetzt noch machen kann.
Okay, wenigstens irgendwas.
Ich finde, es ist eine Drohne.
Wir können eigentlich das Geld zusammenlegen, dann brauchen wir nur noch 5k oder sowas.
Ich glaube, wir können crossen.
Was hast du gekauft?
Help, jetzt.
Dinger, wir brauchen jetzt Hilfe und Job für dich.
Hahaha.
Wir machen jetzt hier keinen Job, erstmal so.
Guck, wenn wir die Suche machen, haben wir eh genug.
Ja.
Was denn?
Von rechts von euch sind Gegner.
Das haben wir, wie wir immer wieder zum Damm hochkommen, Alter.
Blau sind Gegner, die werden aber beschossen von weiter hinten.
Okay.
Ja, wir sollen...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es so gut ist, wenn wir hier mitten auf dem Feld...
Ja, die crossen.
Guck, es ist echt so gut, ich kann von hier oben.
Ey, was ist denn das für alles?
Die müssen selber crossen.
Ah, die müssen jetzt auch rennen.
Die gehen in das Haus hier bei Blau rein.
Ich hab immer nur noch ne Fischbüge.
Wir können auch hochgehen, auch in Power und dann runterfliegen.
Wir müssen...
Lass links rum, lass einfach links rum.
Wir sind jetzt in dem Haus bei Blau drin.
Ja, cool.
Okay, ich komm mit.
Natürlich ist der Suchtauftrag auch wieder so beschissen.
Hello.
Ihr campst garantiert wieder in den Häusern irgendwo.
Ich geh rein, lass mich reinkönnen.
Bisschen nackig.
Ich hab ne Fischbüge, seht ihr?
Cool, ich bin reich, aber immer noch useless.
Lass mal noch Geld, lass mal noch Geld.
Money, money.
Lass mal in der Zone in so ein Haus reingehen und dann rückt ihr ab.
Wir müssen vor.
Monka-Zone.
Die von rechts kommen.
Ey, lass mal links, lass mal links.
Ah, wir sind schon schon.
Wir sind in der Zone, damit sind wir jetzt schon schon.
Nee, nee.
Doch.
Ja, da.
Aber da sind wir schon.
Ey, ey, ey.
Mach mal mit, mach mal mit.
Nimm mal das Popkel direkt mal.
Ja, ich schwärm's schon, das Fisch schon muss jetzt eigentlich mal weggehen.
Ja, du kommst hoch, aber...
Okay, hier sind noch Kästen drin.
Wir kommen hoch, wir kommen hier hoch.
Wir wollen nicht weggehen, weil du noch mit der Gasmuskne reinlaufen könntest.
Da vorne wollen die Leute die Werkstatt verhindern.
Wo?
Das ist oben, das ist oben.
Nee, das ist unten.
Ah, das ist unten.
Hier.
Aber mit 36 Sekunden pusht die Zone.
Ich seh's Max links oben, links oben, da oben!
Was?
Ich seh's!
Team-Vibe, Team-Vibe, ne doch nicht Team-Vibe!
What?
Wo lacht denn der?
Das war nicht mein Kill, hast du ihn gedownt Max?
Ich hab ihn gedownt, ja.
Wir wissen jetzt aber, dass wir kommen, ne?
Ja, jetzt hast du recht.
Ey, was ist das für eine richtige Kniper-Sau, wirklich?
Ey, nochmal!
Von ganz oben, von ganz oben, von ganz oben!
Von oben wird die Sniper-Sau!
Was ist das für eine richtige Sniper-Sau?
Ey, komm jetzt weg, das hier weg!
Weg, weg, weg, weg, weg!
Mit Wachs hinterher!
Ah, jetzt!
Herzlichen Glückwunsch, jetzt!
Wollen wir noch einen Top-Gas-Schein nehmen?
Hier?
Ach, da geht's nicht.
So.
Sollen wir hoch?
Wir müssen hoch.
Ja, okay.
Weißt du, wie es geht?
Wo kommt denn hier was?
An der Seite, aber das ist so offen!
Ääääh!
Kennst du einen bitte?
Das ist die Einzige.
Wo kommt denn hier was?
An der Seite, aber das ist so offen!
Ääääh!
Kennst du einen bitte?
Das ist die Einzige.
Wo kommt denn hier was?
An der Seite, aber das ist so offen!
Ääh!
Kennst du einen bitte?
Das ist die Einzige.
Moritz, das ist voll lustig, aber wir machen das.
Wir können auch rechts rumgehen.
Rechts…
Nee, im Scheißdreck, da kommen alle, Alter.
Gegen Heathcote, wir gehen sneaky weg.
Da killen wir alle.
Wir gehen sneaky, wir gehen sneaky.
Ey, lass doch mal, was du damit machtest.
Kommt ihr mal Platten, du hast null.
Hier, Platten.
Ein Stück.
Äh, wir können doch UAVs kaufen, ne?
einer geld gibt kann man vorbeilaufen
ja das ist übelst das ist das ist wirklich big brain big brain
chat
ich hab den url wie soll man den schon ausmachen oder noch warten
weg ich habe nichts ich habe keinen laut von links kommt gleich noch einer
etwas
Ja, die sind alle Brots, so wie dein Clan-Tag.
Lass den mal killen in dem Haus.
Ja, ja, ja.
Da wäre er noch, ne? Da wäre er noch.
Von oben, vom Damm schießt er.
Auf der Kaufstation, auf der Kaufstation, wo der Damm steht, Leute.
Wo ist er?
Auf dem Damm wird gesniped.
Auf dem Damm snipen die auf uns, die wissen, dass wir sind.
Hier, in der Richtung.
Was?
Ja, der ist rausgesprungen.
Ja, den haben wir gesucht.
Er hatte 0,0 Fotos auf mich, obwohl ich noch neben ihm gerannt habe.
Den Typ haben wir gesucht.
Auf dem Damm mit Sniper, hier direkt vom Damm.
Hier ist ein Drop.
Können wir da hoch?
Ja, aber da kann man hoch.
Da hält dann der Sniper.
Ich versuch's mal.
Da hinten beim Damm.
Die kommen jetzt auf den Damm, auf der Brücke vom Damm.
Okay.
Das sind drei Stück, glaube ich.
Ja, wirklich, ich hab die noch so schnell gehilft, ich konnte sie halt nicht mehr...
Oh Mann, warte mal.
Hier ist immer schlecht.
Links in das Haus rein, links in das Haus rein.
Ja, ich bin jetzt vor.
Ihr habt echt gute Zoni gerade, ihr müsst jetzt auch nicht...
Ja, dann kann ich gleich losfahren.
Ich bin noch raus und...
Aber es ist gleich Ende.
Da hinten rennen die weg.
Ja, okay, dann fahr ich los.
Jo.
Das habt ihr.
Was sollen sie wegrennen?
Vom Blick an du, lass lieber das Haus nehmen.
Wir können auch in dem Haus hier bleiben, ne?
Vorne liegt da noch ein Drop, aber ich weiß nicht, ob wir da raus können.
Wir brauchen den Drop, oder?
Naja, ich könnte ihn gebrauchen, aber muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Sven, was hast du für eine Waffe?
Eine AUG.
AUG passt schon.
Dann hol dir den.
Dann hol dir den echt.
Oben, wir müssen...
Die sind hinten rum weggerannt.
Hey, da hoch.
Die können jetzt raus.
Die sind da oben bei dem Pinsel rum.
Könnten hier auch noch welche drin gekämpft haben.
Okay, ich gucke jetzt.
Ich hol mir schnell noch meinen Drop und dann...
Zum Glück hat mich da keiner erwischt, ja.
Von oben, von da.
Ja, das meine ich auch.
Da oben war ein volles Sniper.
Wir müssen rechts rum hoch gehen.
Wir müssen hier rum hoch gehen.
Da sind immer noch Sniper da oben.
Ja, wir haben nicht so viel Wahl mehr, glaube ich.
Ja.
Ey, lass mal links gucken, links gucken.
Ja, aber wir müssen rechts rum gehen.
Ja, lass da trotzdem nach links gucken.
Wir sind hier safe, wenn wir hier rum gehen.
Ja, aber die da oben noch sind, Diggi.
Hier, die Coole hier.
Ab hier können wir durch die Zone rein.
Ohne Gefahr von links.
Zum Rechts von dir war ein Gegner bei uns, aber nicht sicher.
Der Huppe.
Hier ist sie.
Lass mal hier unten checken.
Unten clearen.
Ich füge, ich füge.
Sieht leer aus.
Nein, rennt er nicht.
Da unten.
Lass nicht.
Wir sind hier aber drin.
Wir sind hier drin.
Hier, lass doch.
Da unten ist auch einer.
Nur von der Antenne können die uns von oben holen.
Oh, ja, Digger.
Wenn wir wirklich gespielt haben, sind einfach euch.
Ruhig von der Antenne.
Ist eine Schießnicht.
Ja, die haben auf mich geschossen zuerst.
Hier oben ist auch noch einer.
Lass die zuerst mal oben.
Wenn wir die holen, können wir direkt unten.
Pock.
Gegen zwei, gegen drei.
Ja, lass Schäden rüberkommen.
Die müssen gleich kommen.
Wir können da einfach gucken.
Die sind da unten.
Ah, ist doch.
Alle?
Ja, ja.
Oh, Gott.
Die sterben, die haben einen Sniper.
Der ist hinter der Barriere da.
Die peaken halt einfach.
Ja, nicht peaken.
Wir haben hier die Zone.
Einer ist, einer ist hier.
Einer ist hier.
Das ist ein Sniper.
Bei Ross ist ein Sniper.
Warte, bis die offen auf der Straße stehen.
Was sollen die machen?
Einer ist hier.
Einer ist los hier.
Wir sind locating.
Okay, ich schuhe rechts rum.
Der hat auf jeden Fall keinen Schiff mehr gehabt, aber er ist eh wieder.
Ja, wo ist denn die Zone?
Da ist sie.
Ja, da kommt die doch.
Lass doch einfach.
Die stehen gleich alle auf der Straße.
Ja, ich hasse das hier.
Du siehst halt wirklich die Zone so wenig.
Hier ist einer bei mir.
Bei mir.
Gegenüber von mir.
Wo, Max?
Einer down.
Hier bei mir.
Gegenüber.
Bam.
Das war übelst useless, die Runde, oder?
Ich sag doch, Chat.
Only wins.
Easy wins vor allem.
Ich hab keinen Win-Counter.
Keck, weh, lol, HD.
Wenn du wissen möchtest, wie viele Zuschauer ich hab, musst du seine Zuschauer einfach durch 1 teilen.
So viel mehr hat der.
Du kannst das Komma verschieben um zwei Stellen.
Aber bei mir ist ja auch nicht viel.
Ich hause dich danach dann.
Oder mal gucken, wir spielen ja noch eine Weile.
Ich bin da eben.
Jawohl.
Ist er.
Was ein geiles Game.
War schon ein bisschen.
Ey, aber du bist...
Übel sinnlos verreckter Anfang, ey.
Ja, warum?
Jetzt ist es wieder frei.
Ich sag nicht immer durch.
Das ist es.
Na, Chat, ich sag doch.
Nur easy.
Wohin ist es heute?
Es ist so anstrengend, das Game teilweise.
Manchmal gar nicht.
Es ist irgendwie merkwürdig.
Manchmal hast du 10 Runden am Stück.
Da geht es übelst ab.
Und du denkst, oh ja, easy, kein Problem.
Und manchmal hast du Runden, die sind übel stressig.
So, hab ich irgendwas übersehen im Chat?
Kurz hochgucken.
Tainser, ja, wenn du Sachen freispielen willst, ist Shipment das Beste.
Kann man was gucken?
Ne, passt.
Der Rauch der Explosion nutzt, um sich zu repositionieren.
Das war eher Glück.
Ey, ich hab gedacht, der pusht.
Ich schmeiß mal ein C4 vor, aber wenn Rauch da ist, dann nix wie weg.
Weil ich hatte keinen Schimmer mehr, wo der ist.
Aber anscheinend ist der gar nicht auf mich gegangen, sondern in die andere Richtung.
Jetzt ruckelt es wieder.
MonkaS, warum?
Das ist teilweise total, total random.
Vor allem mit OBS auf, hab ich irgendwie viel weniger FPS.
Aber Warshorn ist eh grottig programmiert.
Ich seh jetzt ja teilweise, wie die Sachen nicht nachgeladen werden.
Ja, ja, alles gut.
Wie findest du die Performance von Warshorn auf dem PC?
Nicht gut.
Also für die Optik und überhaupt, das Game ist sehr, ja, so halbe Arschbacke gemacht.
Achtung.
Was darf's sein?
Storage Schau.
Wir können doch mal zur TV-Station.
Ah, macht, such's dir aus.
Die TV-Station wird die Hölle los.
Nee, lass wieder Storage Schau, sind wir schon die Profis mittlerweile.
Guck mal, jetzt haben wir sogar eine Kaufe direkt an Storage Schau.
Besser geht's doch nicht.
Tommy, klar, ich glaub, das wird lange dauern.
Spieleentwicklung ist, ich spiel gerne, aber Spieleentwicklung ist irgendwie nicht meins.
Hat mich auch null interessiert bisher.
Der Sound der anderen beiden müsste jetzt aber eigentlich besser passen als am Anfang.
Müsste jetzt deutlich einfacher zu hören sein.
Ja, weg jetzt wieder null.
Ich seh, die bist du auch da, aber ich hab mitgefroren, einfach so den Mütter.
Ich bin da.
Oh, du Scheiße, das ist das halbe Flugzeug.
Nur die drei.
Naja, keine Skills.
Auf gut Glück hier rein, ah, okay.
Schieb dir diese komische Platte rein, Alter.
Mr. Heisenberg müssen wir eliminieren.
Hier muss auch noch ein bisschen vieles drin, aber ich find keine.
Ja, aber hier müssten viele sein.
Die sind bestimmt aufs Schwimmbad gedroppt.
Ich hab immer noch keine Platte gefunden.
Ja, der Typ ist direkt hier vorne neben dem Storage Town.
Ah, Stopping Power.
Jetzt kriegen sie auf den Sack.
Jetzt machen wir so platt. Den Heisenberg.
Sollen wir die direkt überraschen?
Ah ne, die gehen jetzt gerade rüber zur Lagerhalle.
Ah!
Heißt nicht.
Ja, die Lagerhalle ist so schlecht da hinten.
Warum? Zum reincampen?
Ja, zum reincampen.
So bist du im Spielstil der meisten.
Ja, unbedingt!
Wollen wir die pushen oder nicht?
Ja.
Da landet einer.
Hab den gesehen.
Auf dem Dach hier ist einer gelandet gerade.
Der Tank, ey.
Ja.
Oh, irgendwie kriegt der Shots von wo ganz anders nach.
Von da hinten.
Ich glaub vielleicht noch von der...
Oh man, die sind bloß bei mir sogar.
Was? Oh!
Aber einer müsste hier sein, oder?
Oder ist er verreckt?
Hast du einen?
Team eliminiert.
POG.
Ja, what?
Da fehlt noch einer.
Aber die haben auf mich geschossen, als ich dann oben drauf war.
Ich hab keine Platten mehr.
Da schießt irgendjemand anderes noch hoch auf die Station.
Ist auch wirklich schwierig hier gerade zu...
Oh fuck.
Nicht hoch gehen.
Bitte.
Ja, ich...
Dann geh ich wieder, oder?
Fünf Armour-Bots.
Ich hör dich gleich.
Hier.
Hat jemand...
Hat jemand noch Platten?
Ne.
Dann lass weg.
Komm, dann...
Ja, hier liegt die Armour-Bot.
Ich seh die, komm her.
Ich hab die jetzt direkt getropft, weil ich brauch auch auflassen.
Wo geht's denn hier rein?
Wo geht's denn hier rein in das Kackdinger?
Gehen wir jetzt, oder was?
Überall.
Ich hab da schon ein bisschen mit den Händlern angefangen.
Ja, die schießen von oben.
Ich seh den von oben.
Jo.
Ich mach den einen raus.
Viel zu schlecht.
Wenn die aimt hier dafür.
Ne, ich...
Oh mein Gott.
Das Problem ist, wenn wir das crossen wollen, dann...
Ja, ich...
Hier, Achtung, sie aimt schon auf uns mit Zielfernrohr hier.
Ja, mit dem Sniper.
Ne.
Das ist...
Ja, lass lieber ins Schwimmbad gehen.
Ja, lass uns verpissen.
Sollen ruhig herkommen.
Ich hab richtig aufs Maul bekommen, als ich darüber wollte.
Au, au.
Egal.
Sollen die doch.
Die werden uns eh nicht treffen.
Eigentlich voll ungefährlich, was die jetzt grad machen halt.
Das ist...
Sieht immer nur bedrohlich aus irgendwie.
Looten wir lieber noch ein paar Sachen hier.
Wenn noch was da ist.
Kiste ist noch da.
Alles.
Kiste.
Ah, hier ist was für dich.
Bist du auf irgendwas hinaus?
Ne, ne, ne.
Was ist das?
Und es stinkt.
Komm kurz.
Das...
Das stimmt, ja.
Ah, excellent.
Um Himmels willen war das groß.
Oh, p identical.
Ich seh mich da schon irgendwie, muss ich sagen.
Du bist größer in zo'n ganzes Model Physics.
Ja, nass.
Kommt nie auf die Größe an.
Braucht ihr noch Platten?
Mit Geräusch gerade.
Ach guck mal, da hinten tropft weiter die Tanke.
Lass mal kurz den Auftrag nehmen,
dann wissen wir, wo es hingeht.
An der Tanke, wo wir vorhin so viel Stress hatten,
haben sich einen Auftrag gegönnt.
Wo ist denn das 1-Höhe?
Morgen per Corona.
Oh, jetzt habe ich meinen Stopping-Power rausgetauscht.
Big Brain Move.
Nein.
Mann, jetzt machst du...
Oh.
Ja, das sind die, die draufgekauft haben.
Die haben draufgekauft, aber die haben uns das irgendwie auch schon...
Oh, vor uns Gegner.
Was? Okay.
Kontakt.
Oh mein Gott, ja.
Oha, wie viele?
Oha, oha.
Wir haben da ein Problem.
Okay, okay, okay.
Weg, weg.
Poggers.
Alter, nix.
Ich bin gestunt, ich kann nicht weg.
Ich muss.
Die sind schon drin.
Die sind schon in der Leiste.
Ja, okay, das war's.
Ich bin da noch drin, ne?
Mhm.
Die sind schon in der Leiste.
Ich kann die leider...
Ich bin abgehauen, gerade mit dem LKW,
weil ich sonst schon gestorben wäre.
Tröge.
Viel Spaß machen.
Ja, ich hole dich ab, wenn du willst.
Morgen, KS.
Ich glaube, wir sind immer noch von allen gerettet.
Schrägstrich.
Retten wir den nicht, oder wer?
Ja, ich gehe doch schon...
Ach, einer down.
Perfekt.
Ich hätte abhauen sollen.
Ja, meine ich auch.
Nicht sinnlos rumsitzen, einfach abhauen.
Ja, Moritz, wohin?
Reppi, ja.
Wir haben schon einen...
Gleich, gleich ist Respawn.
Ich stehe da nicht hin.
Er steht dann...
Wohin?
Ich stehe mich hier.
Ja, ich stehe mich auch nicht.
Ich bin ehrlich.
Aber unsere...
Unsere Zielkonsole wird da vielleicht noch schimmeln.
Easy.
Pass.
Pass, Manni.
What the...
Wie kommt der gestunt so schnell dahin?
Ach, das war keine Stunt, das war eine Flash.
Geil.
Keck, W, Alter.
Alter, wir bleiben einfach nur im Spawn stehen im Gulag und es funktioniert.
Oh, nice, ihr habt genug Money.
Das ist knifflig gerade, ey.
Weil...
Wir da oben vielleicht den Tod hören bei der Kaufstation.
Äh.
War ich hier?
Was ist das denn mit dir?
Komm noch mit.
Ich lauf da hin.
Ich war doch da nicht hin.
STBA 42, dankeschön.
Sieben Monate.
Huge.
Huge IQ Subscription.
Ah, die will, dass ich mein Loadout abhole.
Ja, ja.
Ich werde es nie verstehen, wie manche in Spielen positionieren.
Danke.
Wollen wir zum Loadout-Job oder wollen...
Jawohl, aber der...
Okay, ich...
Der kommt echt alleine runter.
Ja, also, Vollgas.
Aber da lagen noch...
Hat jemand am Anfang...
Bei euch sind Waffen, oder?
Dann loote ich jetzt schnell mal da, bevor wir da hingehen.
Nee, einfach drauf reingehen.
Ja, hat jemand schon...
Sind das...
Schneibers.
Oh, Wahnsinn.
13 Schuss.
Huge.
Für was?
M4.
Aber ich nehme jetzt eh gleich mal ein Overkill-Trap.
Und gut, es...
Da habe ich wieder...
Wenn man nur noch in Emojis redet.
Pog.
Pogu.
Und WU.
Ja, das ist hier die Loadjob, oder?
Genau, und dann hole ich den Heli.
Hat jemand ein Profi-System?
Nee.
Nein.
Die London Street Sniper.
Aber ich habe eine tolle Drohne.
Ja.
Äh, dodge die Raketen mit der Drohne.
Ich muss jetzt fangen.
Wobei, ich wurde jetzt echt selten im Media.
Kommt man hier überhaupt rauf?
Ah, so.
Wir müssen runterkommen einfach.
Äh.
Jetzt.
Warte, warte, warte.
Da liegt noch ein Batzen Geld.
Hier hinten liegt auch noch Zeug.
Please, go catch me.
Ja, wo bist du?
Links.
Was ist der Plan so?
Äh, vielleicht fahre ich zum Quarry mal.
Hoch und weit.
Hoch und weit, genau das auch.
Über den Waldwurf.
Mannschaftsbau.
Und hier auch eine Kaufkarte?
Ja.
Wie, das ist komplett random irgendwie.
Die ist da oben an diesem Monument.
Ja.
Also, hier sieht es eigentlich nicht aus.
Dann steckt die aus.
Wir sollten gucken, dass wir vielleicht ein bisschen Kohle kriegen.
Ein paar UAVs und Killstreaks kaufen können, weil...
Wo ist man hier?
Und Schuss und auf jeden Fall Munition brauchen wir noch.
Also ich...
Bin auf dem Weg.
Aber da wird vielleicht auch jemand kämpfen.
Ich sehe jetzt gerade nichts.
Okay.
Ich sehe da noch schon welche.
Soll...
Äh...
Wollen wir mal abspringen?
Okay.
Excellent.
Nein, den heli mal hier oben.
Alles gut.
Das ist ja relativ safe.
Wir sind, ähm...
Bei der anderen Kaufstation.
Wir sind bei der anderen Kaufstation.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Aber wir brauchen...
Die Kaufstation liegt hier.
Also eine Runde Platten.
Ach, und hier hast du eine Sicherungsstation.
Ja, ich habe eine Runde Platten für dich, wenn du willst.
Okay, ich komme.
Hier ist eine Sicherungsstation.
Ich habe eine Mine draufgelegt.
Danke.
Warte.
Ich habe noch genau 200.
Passend.
Ah.
Ja, lass hochlaufen.
Das geht hier, glaube ich, nicht.
Soll ich mit dem Heli drunter kommen?
Ne, passt.
Komm, glaube ich.
Hier liegt noch eine.
Die kann ich nicht aufnehmen.
Ja, eine.
Ich habe auch fünf.
Ich habe auch zwei.
Ich habe vier.
Ja, das ist...
Von wo schießt?
Wo ist Shootin'?
Hilf?
Ja, lass mal irgendwie eine ordentliche Posit suchen.
Heli?
Gut, dann.
Ich habe einen Profi sitzen auf dem Heli jetzt schon.
Ja.
Wir brauchen unbedingt Muni hier.
Wir sind doch echt gut hier.
Hier oben.
Bravo, bravo.
Jetzt sollen wir mal einen linken Profi-Profi sammeln.
Hast ein Ges...
Sehr gut.
Ja.
Warte, lass uns einen Schutz hier sammeln.
Der Heli sollte eigentlich hier safe sein.
Ich habe 210 Schuss und ich habe alles voll.
Ja, ist gut.
Was brauchst du, Max, was für Muni?
Assault Rifle.
Ich bin ja immer noch hier wie Sand am Meer.
Ja, ich habe auch nichts.
So, ist doch was schon aus, vielleicht.
Ja, da war ich gerade.
Da war nichts drin, oder was?
Ne.
Okay, ich habe 5k.
Okay.
Wir könnten jetzt eigentlich auch noch so eine Taufe schieben.
Oh Leute, guck mal, guck mal.
Der hat mich gesehen und ist umgedreht.
Falsch hier, Mern, oder?
Ja, der hat mich gesehen und ist umgedreht.
Der geht zu dem Drop.
Der loodet seinen Drop da.
Ja, moin.
8000 Meter weg.
Nein.
Der weiß aber, dass der...
Der hat Angst.
Da unten rennen noch Leute über das Feld.
Oh, der hat Angst, der hat Angst.
Doppelteam, da wird der Sniper gewonnen.
Achtung.
X-Snipes, HD.
Sein Team, Achtung, von links.
Das ist das andere Team, das pushen jetzt.
Das soll jetzt den pushen, komm.
Oh, ich habe ihn gedownt sogar, Lol.
Welchen?
Ich habe ihn gedownt, den da.
Den Fallschirmjäger da.
Da sind noch zwei Leute.
Ich habe keine Muni dafür.
Ich brauche jetzt eine Munibot, sondern ich verpiss dich.
Oh mein Gott, vor mir.
Was?
Wo?
Vor mir.
Wie?
Wie hier drin, meine Leiche.
Wie denn?
Hier, ja, hier.
Was, ich seh ihn, was?
Nice.
Die kommt raus.
Ja, ja.
Ey, ich habe ihn nur getroffen, weil er weggehüpft ist.
Ok, wir können dich kaufen eigentlich, klar.
Wo ist der hingefallen, wo ist der loot hingefallen?
Hier.
Wo hadert der nicht.
Junge.
Ich take mal deinen Cash.
Du musst aber, wenn du mich kaufst, den Schuh schneiden.
Ja, können wir doch machen.
Keine Ahnung von wo es sniped.
Da hinten.
Zack, schneiden.
Du kaufst mich doch nicht.
Shoot.
Shoot Snipes.
X, X, X des Snipes.
HD, Alter.
Gehst du da jetzt?
Ohne mich zu holen.
Da ist wohl noch einer.
Warte.
Da rechts.
An der Mauer, oder?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ahhhh.
Will HD.
Da seh ich mich.
Einer geht down.
Lass mal noch fehlen.
Da müsste auch noch Nude liegen.
Ja, also einer lebt noch von denen.
Ja, ich komm von hinten.
Ich geh von hinten.
Eigentlich leben, da müssen zwei noch leben.
Der eine wird wahrscheinlich wiederbelebt.
Der ist hier.
Ich guck mal HD.
Okay, moving.
Okay.
Oben drauf, oder was?
Bei grün, bei grün, bei grün.
Ich guck mal der Drohne, wo die sind.
Ich mach.
Sind das Zeug von denen?
Ich hab jetzt Dead Silence drin und stell es mich ran.
Was in 100 Jahren spielt.
Die sind richtig schlecht.
Ich seh nicht, wo die sind.
Auch nicht.
Jetzt war es 87, also.
Waren die unten drin, oder was?
Ja, die sind unten drin.
Nee, oben drauf.
Der ist oben drauf gerannt.
Ich bin grad oben drauf.
Ey, du siehst.
Du müsstest diese Rauten sehen, irgendwo.
Nö.
Irgendwas beschießt mich.
Von der Straße aus.
Man sieht immer die Rauten.
Markier doch hier.
Ich kann da grad nicht rausfacen.
Ja, Tidal Resistance.
Die haben irgendwas dagegen.
Ich bin von hinten.
Alter.
Sag, wenn du Engaged, dann guck ich raus.
Okay.
Das ist nicht viel, aber es funktioniert ehrlich gesagt.
Jetzt eins.
Ähm, wir sind aber richtig gut in der Zone hier.
Ja, Airfield ist eigentlich okay in hier.
Da hinten!
Wir forschen drüber.
Lass hochgehen, lass hochgehen.
Ja.
Der kommt auch hoch.
Der andere ist hinter der Mauer.
Einer rechts.
Ich hab einen Doppelspeicher.
Ich hab einen gekauft.
Ich seh grad nix.
Wir müssen an den hinter uns denken, ne?
Ammo break.
Einer K.O., der ist K.O.
Da hinten läuft noch einer.
An blau.
Von hinten, von hinten, von hinten!
Der snidet mich an!
Achtung!
Sollen sie doch machen was.
Ne, der kann voll...
Der ist ziemlich nah.
Der ist da ungefähr, wo das Squad steht.
Hier, seht ihr ihn?
Oh ja, ich seh ihn.
Sollen wir ihn nicht pushen?
Ich hab keine Muni, immer noch nicht.
Der ist auf mir drauf.
Also, da ist glaub ich auch nur einer.
Kick los, kick los bei dir.
Von hinten, von hinten, noch einer.
Fuck.
Wo ist der andere hier?
Einer fehlt, einer fehlt.
Von hinten kommt auch noch ein Gig, ne?
Oh mein Gott, geil.
Alter.
Überall, überall.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich brauch die Muni.
Was zum Teufel?
Was hält der aus?
Team wipe.
Okay, top.
Was hält der aus?
Kommen denn die alle her?
Weiß nicht, aber ich hol alles.
Was zum...
Geil.
Achtung, da waren Steps.
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Ich hab den...
Eine Team down.
Ja, loote mich, loote mich.
Auf dem Hügelmot.
Welcher Hügel?
Auf dem...
Von uns hier.
War der Mate von uns?
Wo ist...
Wo ist die Leiche?
Der kann aber echt nicht mehr viel ausgehalten haben, der Typ, ey.
Also...
Doch, der hat, er hat wie viele Shots noch gebraucht, blut...
Bei dem Hügel oder was?
Bei Grün?
Glaube ich auf Steps gehört, aber in dem Spiel ist alles möglich.
Das kann ja unten drin sein, gell?
Wir haben ne absolute Mülleimer-Pose hier.
Das ändert Offen-Air-Field im Open-Field, Alter.
Oh mein Gott.
Ich find die gar nicht so schlecht, die Pose.
Ja, ja, ja.
Also, ihr hättet, ihr hättet gerade genug Kohle, falls irgendwo ne Kaufe hier ist.
Da wär eine, äh, zwischen uns sind halt Gegner.
Egal, lass es so ein bisschen von hinten...
Ja.
Das ist zu...
Hier können wir auch in die Grube, gell?
Ja, ist Gott sei Dank zu risky, aber...
Da rennt einer.
Nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht.
Ja, ja, ich geh, ich renn drauf, lass mich von innen holen.
Jetzt, Leute, easy, easy win, ich sag's euch.
Die machen das, die zwei.
Ich finde, es sind zwei Leute direkt vor dem Ding.
Komm hier vielleicht rein.
Einer.
Einer rechts hinter uns.
Einer hinter uns.
Steady.
Ihr müsst ihn holen.
Wollt ihr hinter uns?
Ich hol den vor uns.
Der arme Junge hatte...
Der andere kommt, glaub ich, hinter.
Der ist oben drauf, der ist oben drauf.
Wo?
Du kannst hinten auch raus...
Achso.
Was ist der?
Wie war's?
Komm da nicht hoch.
Das ist ein Dreckspiel.
Ne, du.
Wo bist du?
Der retzt sich jetzt.
Okay.
Oh, Mann, ne Mede.
Aber da ist noch irgendeiner close.
Geht's ihm zumindest.
Der hat mich wohl übel low geschossen.
Ich bin dann extra da.
Wie crossen wir die Kacke jetzt hier?
Gar nicht.
Cool.
Wie crossen wir die gar nicht?
Wir müssen.
Aber da war eigentlich irgendeiner noch close.
Egal.
Lass mal aus dem nächsten Hügel rennen.
Oder wir holen...
Oh, hinter euch.
Achso, da haben wir Break.
Hol ihn dir.
Oh, ich seh, wie die Zone kommt.
Du musst mich jetzt holen, bitte.
Geil.
Das sind 70 da.
So, wir Max holen?
Könnt ihr machen, ja.
Ja, machen wir.
Komm, geh.
Die ist nicht...
Die ist nicht zugestellt.
Da vorne liegt ein Drop.
Gucken, vielleicht flieg ich direkt zum Drop, Yolo.
Mach das.
Ich hol.
Aber...
Teddy, wir müssen rennen.
Wir müssen rennen.
Ja, geil.
Aber sowas von rennen.
Max macht Drohne.
Ja, ja.
Sobald, Stammen.
Wir wissen jetzt überhaupt nicht, dass wir in den Drop...
Unabfällig.
Also, ich sehe gerade hier...
Da hinten kommt ein Gegner rein jetzt.
Okay, ich gehe jetzt...
Ich gehe jetzt direkt zum Drop.
Ich sehe es.
Zum Glück lasche ich die Schüsse.
Einer hat eine P.
Oh.
Weggesniped noch.
Teddy, wir sind aufgeteilt, ja?
Wir sind absolut tot, Motz.
Nein, wir sind nicht tot.
Ihr macht das.
Ich brauche eine Platte.
Ich...
Oh, ich habe keine Platte hier.
Oh, einer sniped dich.
Nein.
Ich werde in der Luft geholt.
Oh Gott.
Ja, das war es, Alter.
Nee, dahin.
Ey...
Er sniped mich in der Luft.
Noch elf Gegner kommen.
Ah, okay.
Der hat den Konsolen-Aim...
Hm?
Der hat Konsolen-Aim, Motzmann.
Ja, das war manchmal echt unlucky.
In der Luft.
Next.
Ha.
Er spielt die Zone halt nicht mit.
Der hat eben wieder so unglaublich viel ausgehalten, der eine Gegner, ja.
Wieder 4000 Damage und seltsame Tills oder sowas.
Alter.
Ja, mit Weltrekord-Gameplay wird's nix.
Dann müssten wir ja auch in eine gute Lobby kommen.
Ja, vielleicht erst mal bei Activision anrufen,
ob wir nicht irgendwie ein besseres Matchmaking
kriegen. Ja, das
interessiert auch keinen, ey.
Da musst du schon, wie heißt der?
Witz da. Oder wer auch immer
sein, dann ist kein Ding.
Du bist ein Hotstar.
Das Geile ist,
es sind ja mittlerweile dadurch,
dass sie nicht bestätigen und nichts
dagegen sagen, was Skill-Based Matchmaking
und sowas angeht, sind so viele
Mythen und Gerüchte im Umlauf.
Im Shop-Ofen, ja.
Kann man das in-Game machen?
Nee, kann man nicht.
Mal gucken, wie hart man aufschlagen kann.
Das hört sich aber echt ungesund an.
Fliegen wir mal
gegen die Lagerhalle.
Aber gerade beim Aufschlagen,
Chat,
guck mal.
Gerade beim Aufschlagen merkt man, dass der Surfer
total wenige Ticks hat. Der registriert das
total spät, wenn man auf... Guck mal!
Ach nee, okay, das ist die Zeit abgelaufen.
Da ist man unverwundbar. Aber es ist so,
du schlägst auf und es dauert
irgendwie gefühlt so eine halbe Sekunde,
bis es zählt.
Sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
30 Ticks
for the win.
Cineastische
Experience.
20 Ticks. Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Ach so.
Ich darf nicht so nuscheln, sagt einer.
Alles klar, nuschel ich.
Nuschel ich.
Storage Town?
Das Flugzeug ist sogar ganz gut dafür.
Ja, Mann.
Ein paar 150 Spieler geht nicht mehr?
Doch.
Da landet einer, direkt an gelb.
Direkt neben mir.
Hier ist nix.
Keine Waffe, keine Waffe.
Schütz dich, einer kommt rechts neben uns.
Ich brauch irgendwas.
Hier, direkt hier.
Ich geh wieder zurück, da wo du herkommst.
So, wo ist der nächste?
Excellent.
Komm, noch einer, noch einer.
Ah, Movement.
Please.
Gutes.
Ich hab ne K98, Alter.
Ah, hier ist was Gutes.
Der hat eine M4, hey.
Hier ist noch einer.
Okay.
Sicher, dass du nicht mich gehört hast?
Nee, ich hab zwei. Einer fehlt noch.
Soll ich den...
Was haben wir denn hier für einen Auftrag?
Soll ich den Bounty annehmen?
Da können wir...
Ah, ich dachte, vielleicht kriegen wir den hier.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Hier in der Mitte irgendwo.
Irgendwo bei mir.
Okay, nice.
Alter, wie sie immer genau im richtigen Moment um die richtige Ecke gucken, ja.
Das hätt ich auch mal gerne.
Guck mal, wo der sitzt.
Hier drin.
Erst mal sein Zeug looten hier.
Und dann noch T-Bag.
Was sonst?
Hallo, Ecke?
Please.
So, komm, wir gehen ins Schwimmbad gucken, dass wir da noch ein paar Platten kriegen.
Da liegt noch eine Falle, aber die ist richtig schmutzig.
Ich hab eine M4 und eine P90.
LMG.
Und wir haben ganz gut...
Wir haben richtig gut Geld.
So, hier, Kaufi am Start.
Jawoll.
Das kaufen direkt.
Ich leg dir hin.
Ja, und Kaufi direkt noch Platten.
Brauchst keine Platten mehr.
Oh, gehen wir mal.
Rund ins Schwimmbad gucken.
Steh die Herzen?
Also okay.
Warte, ich hol dir noch eine Platte.
Siehst, Drohne.
Hat auf jeden Fall...
Braucht auf jeden Fall Geld wert.
High Impact.
Da ist sie.
Also ohne die Drohne wären wir schon lange tot gewesen.
Oh doch, jetzt die Pushtür.
Geht jetzt hoch zum Feld.
Wo ist denn da was?
Hier.
Ah.
Okay.
Da unten liegt noch Munni.
Wir können zusammenlegen und uns noch einen URV holen.
Ich krieg einen Shot.
Durch die Wand?
Irgendwo ist ja noch ne Kiste da.
Wahrscheinlich oben drauf.
Ich hab grad dieses Geräusch bekommen.
Wenn ein Shot so ein Zentimeter an einem Kopf rüber fliegt.
In dem Haus drin.
Wollen wir uns noch nen URV kaufen?
Können wir machen eigentlich.
Das können wir wirklich tun.
Ich leg, ich leg mal.
Ne, die hat schon vier.
Du kannst eine kaufen.
Brauchst die einfach.
Du kannst dir auch eine hier.
Soll ich sie gleich zünden?
Ne, ne.
Die wär noch mehr was drin, als die da oben ist.
Ja.
So.
Ja noch mehr was drin, als die da oben.
Ich weiß nicht.
So kurz schauen.
Wo gehen wir denn hin am besten?
Wollen wir da runter?
Wirklich mal runter pushen zu gelb?
Oder wollen wir hoch.
Oder wollen wir hoch zum Airport?
Weil wir pushen ansonsten.
Gelb macht keinen Sinn.
Ja.
Ich hab den Rocklaunch dabei, weil ich das nur gescheitert als 2 Dörfer gefunden hab.
EtwasWeh Keith.
Ist wieder erstaunlich ruhig gerade.
Viel zu ruhig.
Man hört nicht mal einen Schuss.
Kann ich dir versichern.
Das ändert sich gleich.
Okay.
was ist die Quote auf deine Versicherung?
auuuu
Gutsch Prime Sub
Da war doch schon der erste Schuss
Waren wir eigentlich klar
Mann, nicht mal ein Gutsch Prime Sub für dich
Ja, wo, wo?
Unter uns, oder?
Hat der oben in der Luft geschossen?
Oder ist der im Klo?
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich
Wann hast du den jetzt organisiert,
dass er kurz schießt?
Ja, natürlich
Ich hab auf dem 2. Bildschirm gestreamsnipert
Im 2.
Ich seh hinter dir
Handy, ne, ist doch mobile
Das ist wirklich erstaunlich
ruhig
Hier ist auch noch ungelootet, der ganze Air Force
Da ist ein komplettes Dreiertchen gelandet
Versteh ich nicht
Vielleicht hast du ja spontan
keinen Bock mehr auf die
Die haben sich gedacht, lass uns für uns liegen
Das war ein Stream Sniper
Die wollten nicht
Ja, lass halt die 2 hier machen
Ja, oben zum Beispiel ist gelootet
Also hier sind Kisten auf und so
Hier nicht
Boah, scheiße
Jetzt haben die das wieder an das
Die haben so gelootet
Wie man nicht looten sollte
Da kommst du nicht hin an den Aufzeig
Da musst du wieder halbe Parcours weg machen
Hier sehen wir wohl auch ne Kiste
Hier rum kommst du
Was ist das denn, Alter?
Oh
Hier kommt man hoch
Das will ich sehen
Zeugschmuck
Hey, warte mal
Wo ist der denn?
Der ist eben in diesem Flugzeugbeladungsding, oder?
In diesem Tunnel zum Flugzeug
Nee, aber
What the fuck
Wo?
Tower, Tower, Tower
Mockass
Wie alle sitzen wieder
Alle sitzen hier irgendwo
Der Tower hat kurz Beschäftigung mit Aufheben
Moment, hier ist auch verkehrt, oder?
Ich hab noch 2 Raketen, ich glaub ich sag kurz Hallo zu denen
Boah, hier hast du richtig schöne Smoke-Band
Aber beim Crossen jetzt halt nicht
Egal, wir können ja durch den Airport noch bisschen
Wo wollt ihr eigentlich hin?
Zu dem Auftrag
Morgen KS
Ich hab mal eine Rakete reingeschossen
Ein Choker
Oder was?
Ja hoch
Nee, nicht ein Choker, ein RPG
Kommt man hier irgendwie rauf, ne?
Ja doch hier
Ich hab nur drauf geschossen und jetzt bin ich durchgerannt danach
Raid und Switch, oder wie heißt es auf Englisch?
Ähm
Hier war schon jemand
Oder war irgendwer?
Die ist drin, aber egal
Ich mach die alleine halt nur
Ich komm mit
Ist bei euch gerade einer durch irgendein Glas gesprungen?
Äh
Alter, man kann hier nicht durchlaufen
Ich bleib einfach liegen
Hast du irgendeine Idee, wo?
Nee, nee, aber der war ja richtig schlecht
Was war dein Auftrag, Kumpel?
Also ich seh absolut nichts mehr
Äh, das kann eine interessante Queryzone werden
Das warst du unten im Fenster, ne?
Jawoll
Wir können auch da hinten fahren, gell?
Jo, können wir machen
Ich hab hier ein Auto, hat jemand nen Coffee?
Nee
Ich komm zu dir
Aber wir dürfen nicht so lange hier unten rumstehen
Geht ihr?
Meta
Rückwärts fahren
Was machst du?
Poggers Move
Oh Gott
Ja, nicht gegen den Baum
Ich hab gerade auf die Map geguckt
Äh, nach links vielleicht durch den blauen Marker
Okay, das machen wir
Ah, direkt drauf
Das Ding ist aufgehalten
Mach keine...
Ich bin fast tot, aber gut
Brauchst du planen?
Ich dachte, du hast ihn überfahren?
Okay, gut
Aber so ein Trophy hat unser Leben gerettet
Ja man, ich wär nicht mit Trophy, ohne Trophy wär ich da nichts drauf gemacht
Nee, da wär ich echt drauf gewonnen, also mit dem hier
Bleib einfach
Befolge dem Straßenverlauf
Befehl
Wenn möglich, bitte wenden
Was?
Was gibt es denn, wenn es fertig ist?
Da wird auf jeden Fall auch gleich ne Rakete von oben kommen
Ja
Was haben wir...
Oh, Missile Locking
Ich vertraue, ich vertraue, ich vertraue
Warum?
Warum bist du raus, Max?
Missile Locking, nochmal, warum bist du...
Max, hallo?
Weil ihr was von raus erzählt habt
Nee
Achso
Jetzt ist er weg
Ja, dann lass wieder rein
Hinter uns ist noch ein Auto, das können wir nehmen
Wir stehen oben auf dem Dach drauf, ne?
Wir stehen oben auf dem Dach, ja
Wir hätten durchfahren können
Echt, atme ich ins Mikrofon?
Das ist keine Absicht
Ja, wenn er aufhört zu atmen, ist es schwierig
Ja, die haben so echte Bock auf snipen da oben
Da müsste man
Du bist jetzt hier so ein bisschen im Schatten vom Baum, gell?
Guck mal hin
Die haben keine Ahnung
Ich glaube jetzt ist es besser
Wir könnten nochmal so ein Dagger-Rate machen
Da sind ja richtig viele
Lass den Linken mal vielleicht
Aha
Der Linke liegt außerhalb von dem Haus
Das ist schon ein Vorteil
Jawohl, aber dann bleibt da
Da ist sicher auch ein Team drin
Hier hockt 100 pro wieder irgendwas im Haus
Es sitzt immer was im Haus hier
Ja gut, ne?
Ah ja, auf geht's
Weiter ins Haus
Aha
Muss das immer sein?
Ja, wir müssen was killen
Da ist niemand, da ist niemand, da ist niemand
Da ist niemand, da ist niemand
Da ist niemand
Wenn man das dreimal ganz laut zeigt, dann ist das nicht so
Wenn das funktioniert
Ach, das ist da oben
Das ist wie Bloody Mary
Mein Chat hält nicht auf
Oh, die kommen her, gell? Die wissen halt wo wir sind
Jo, jo, jo, jo
Wir haben es markiert mit einem Leucht-Signal
Ich höre ein Auto
Auto, Auto, Auto
Ich glaube die sind gegenüber auf dem Haus stehen geblieben
Nicht auf dem Haus, aber gegenüber auf dem Berg stehen geblieben
Ja, da war ein Auto, gell?
Ja, ja
Oh, die sind close
Close, close, close
Wo sind die?
Close
Kommen wir mal, Hardspeed-Sensor
Erstmal hier ein bisschen Verteidigung aufbauen
Ich seh nix
Ähm, hier
Wo schießt ihr hin?
Random
Einer down
Okay
Wo ist der?
War der unten oder oben?
Aber der...
Hinter dir nochmal, Moritz, auch, gell?
Hier noch drin
Einer fehlt noch
Hinter mir
Ich mach mal Tür zu
Alter, ich darf die Tür nicht zu machen
Ja, das geht nicht
Wir machen das jetzt hier...
Oh
Nein
Das waren die nicht
Das waren die, das waren die
Ja, aber meine Bedrohung ist hier in der Stadt
Ich hab recht auf der Map eingesehen
Achtung, da kommt gleich wieder einer
Ich seh ihn ja immer noch am Leben
Das ist der eine gewesen
Du lootest hier so random immer irgendwelche Dinger, ey
Ich?
Nee, generell in dem Game loot man random immer irgendwelche Dinger
Hey, da müsste einer sein von denen
Gegenüber in Richtung
Der läuft da so sehr schwer die Kopfstütze
Der läuft, dann kommt der wieder her
Ja, ich hab doch 12 Tage
Mhm, aber wir haben keine Kopfstütze
Wir könnten da rüber
Ich mein
Da sind richtig viele
Oh wie viele, guckt mal wie viele Gegner da sind
Hehehe
Ach du heilige
Hammer, endlich haben wir Geld
Das haben wir echt gebraucht
Macht ihr Türen auf und zu?
Wo ist eigentlich meine Waffe hin jetzt?
Bei der ganzen Geschichte
Das war es halt
Sven, du musst immer dich eignen
Ich glaub ich hab die geklaut
Ja
Ja, behalt, behalt
Ah, ja
Ich hab mal
Also ich hab noch ein
Ich hab noch ein ULV
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das jetzt schon machen sollten
Erst mal mal rausgehen
Ich hab die Tür mal ein bisschen aufgehoben
Tja
Wir müssten eigentlich echt noch zu der Kaufstation
Das wäre echt praktisch
Das ist schon so dead
Das werden wir nicht überleben
Hat unser Auftrag auch nicht überlebt
Wir haben so viel Kohle
Doch, der Auftrag war vorbei
Komm, ich mach jetzt mal ein ULV raus
Und wir gucken mal, was wir machen
Das hast du euch beantwortet, oder?
Alles klar, wir sind mittendrin in der Zone
Alter
Da treffen sich gleich zwei Teams an der Kaufstation
Da gehen wir mit drauf und machen die platt
Da gehen zwei Teams an die Kaufstation
Es sind mehr als zwei Teams, es sind drei, drei und zwei
Alter
Wir müssen eigentlich alles
Wir können uns ja auch bekämpfen so leicht
Die sind in den zwei Nachbarhäusern
Da kommt gleich ein Team dazu
Die geht ab in den Killfeed
Ja, hey, rennt einer?
Hier oben ist auch was
Nicht, dass rechts auch Spieler sein können
Ja, ja, rechts auf dem Berg sind auch welche
Wir sind aber mittendrin, wir müssen eigentlich die Zone abwarten
Runde abcamp
Ich hab schon sechs Kills
Ich hab schon ein bisschen was gemacht
Oh
Guck mal, ich hab das beste neue Spray hier
Es ist nichts zu tun, ich T-Bag einfach ein bisschen auf der Stelle
Guck mal, ich zeig dir mal mein neues Spray
Ich hab ein bisschen potentiöse Flex-Moods
Ah ja
Hier leistet Leia, who got owned
Ja, see die wo?
See dem Stroke, oder was?
Das ist High-Octane-Gameplay gerade
Zone ist immer noch gut
Oben bei Grün
Aber die wissen, dass...
Hit, hit, hit
Hier, bei grün.
Da kommt ein Luftschachtel raus.
Ne, da rennt jetzt mega viel da raus.
Hier.
Ich seh den Schachtel.
Einer links noch.
Exzellent.
Schau.
Ich seh den Wind.
Da hinten rennt auch noch einer raus am Haus.
Ich hab ihn tot.
An gelb ist auch noch einer ins Haus gerannt.
Das war jetzt schon nett.
Man sieht so viel mit nötigen Grafik-Settings.
Der eine wurde wiederbelebt, den ich da gedownt hab bei grün.
Achtung auf rechts gucken, die von berg oben.
Der muss jetzt rennen, die müssen jetzt rennen.
Einer down.
Confirmed, ja, einer ist down.
Bist du grad raus? Ja.
K.O.?
Hier, Achtung, bei uns kommt gleich einer.
Ich hab da irgendwas gesehen.
Unten.
Ey, da stehen total viele unter uns.
Unter uns.
Da auch hin.
Hilf mir, hilf mir, hilf.
Helf.
Schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell.
Monka ist.
Und Platten reinschieben.
Ja, erstmal Platten rein.
Wir können ja auch unten rum raus aus dem Haus.
Ich hab wieder alles.
nur noch 8 Gegner
ihr werdet es absolut kosten den Weg da rüber zu machen
so wie ich gerade
von oben
ach du scheiße
kannst du die irgendwie ein bisschen nerven vorne
ich seh die nicht
müssen auch noch irgendwo andere Leute sein
ich hab da keinen Winkel drauf
ok komm YOLO
oben oben oben
wieso haben die denn immer noch Tone
die coolen Menschen
die sind ganz toll sind
lass mal hier kurz warten
ja in den Shop gehen wir nicht
müssen nach links zu bleiben
da mein ich ja
hier hinten oben müssen wir echt zu bleiben
was ist hier im Web
schön
jetzt warten
wenn die oben sind und die Zone reinkriegen
die nächste Zone wird die runter pushen
das ist übrigens 3 gegen 3
ne
hätte ich mich zu zweit
zweit
nächstesisms
gute zone
sehr gute Zone für uns
die müssen kommen
nicht wir
ich glaub mein ich klatschen da dran
guck ich seh niemand da
ich guck oben
doch
die sind noch oben
ok lasst mal jetzt den im Wald rein rennen
das sind 2
und da muss nur einer sein
dann lass ihn ein straight
den Fall
dann haben wir die
ich renne hier einfach im Wald rum
ich sehe es
du isst durch den Wald
Daniel
Achtung, Achtung, du wirst besch...
Okay, Achtung, die sehen dich von da.
Die sind Richtung grün.
Ich kann gerade nicht aufstehen.
Ja, ich auch.
Richtung grün.
Ich habe einen markiert.
Oh, fuck, ich muss jetzt weg.
Poggers!
Monkeys!
Die wollten es wieder wissen.
Die haben bestimmt auch die ganze Runde auf dem Bash gesessen, Alter.
Pogu!
Oh, ich glaube, ich mache kurz Pause und gehe Eis essen.
Hey, ging doch mal.
Und jetzt habe ich nicht aufgenommen, ne?
Das ist quasi unsere Weltrekordrunde.
8 von 5.
Hey, mein Typ hat ihn erstmals aufgesetzt und ich habe ihn irgendwie noch down-displaced mit No-Stroke.
Max am Schwitzen, stellt der Chat korrekt.
Korrekterweise fest, ja.
Das stimmt.
Aber wir schwitzen genauso.
Nee, ich schwitze nicht.
Men's not hot, ja.
Men's not AC.
Ich gehe auch mal kurz aufs Klo.
Es kann sein, dass ich kurz Pause machen muss.
Wartet mal schnell.
Bin gleich wieder da.
2 Minuten.
Easy.
Alles easy heute.
Only easy.
Ay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Stabile Stream, aber...
Nice.
Free Bundle.
Ich glaube, heute haben wir live 2 gemacht, oder?
So, ich mache mal kurz Pause, aber ich bin dann gleich wieder da.
Wie kurz Pause?
So, was sagen Sie, halbe Stunde, 45 Minuten?
Okay.
So in dem Dreh.
Wie viele wins schon?
Ich glaube, 3 heute?
Ja, 3 heute.
Wir haben heute 6.
6.
Ja, mit mir dabei.
3-3.
Halbiert erst mal.
So, Chat, ich bin mal kurz weg.
Ach, mach dir das mal.
Ich sag dir dann Bescheid, wenn ich wieder am Start bin, ne?
Ja, klar.
Ich sprühe mal weiter.
Genau.
Sprühen und beten.
Ja.
Also, bis später.
Macht's gut.
So, Chat, ich bin auch mal weg.
Kann sein, dass ich nachher nochmal onkomme.
Ich muss mal...
Eine Sache muss ich nämlich mal gucken.
Weil, ähm, ach so, ich hauste mal den Vetras, hausten wir mal, ähm, der mit dem ich eben gespielt habe.
Ich muss dann gleich nochmal einstellen, dass ich ein bisschen Noisegate wieder einschalte für mein Mikro, dass ich euch nicht so sehr ins Ohr schnaufe.
Das muss ich nachher machen.
Ähm, wir sehen uns, Leute.
Bis dann.
Raiden wir ihn mal.
Gucken, wer mitkommt.
Der hat es echt verdient.
Die letzten Tage hat er so oft gestreamt.
Auch richtig gute Gameplays am Start gehabt.
Aber wenn du halt immer nur einen Zuschauer hast, stehst du halt im Ranking auch so krass weit unten.
Da hast du keine Chance, mal ein paar abzugreifen.
Guckt einfach mal bei ihm vorbei.
Vielleicht gefällt es euch ja.
Wenn nicht, bin ich nachher wahrscheinlich wieder on.
Also, Chat, bis später.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut.
See you.